bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
podcast probablement aujourd'hui j'ai le
grand plaisir d'accueillir rudolf
meilleur de la chaîne le réveil heures
qui a vraiment une chaîne fantastique
c'est ce genre de chaînes à jacques fin
je me dis c'est quand même fou que ça
existe et que c'est vraiment un crabe le
banc de l'aj que ça n'existe qu'en
français la connaissance il ya vraiment
pas d'équivalent en tant que le fun je
suis resté quelque chose à proposer
salut les déjà merci pour l'invitation
voix pourra discuter un peu bas c'est
une bonne question
alors j'ai vu il ya quelques vidéos
quand même de vulgarisateur qui parlent
plus ou moins de l'environnement il y
avait huit roquettes ou bismarck fait
des vidéos un peu sur le changement
climatique avec veritas ya aussi qui
avait fait une très bonne sur les
arguments qui m'a sociétique mêmes il
m'a vu une très bonne sur la
radioactivité a nui naturelle là qui est
une des dernières vidéos que j'ai fait
après vraiment qu'ils essayent de
centrer sur l'environnement comme moi je
crois pas trop que ça existe après il ya
des bombes ou qu il ya un book sur les
mecs qui ont ces limites planétaires je
pense si tu tapes mook planetary band
harris tu dois tombé dessus et ça tu
peux le suivre un peu et ça a aidé des
vidéos des documents mais c'est déjà une
étape au dessus d'une chaîne youtube
donne l'occasion de te féliciter encore
merci et c'est sûr fait et je suis donc
ravi de te recevoir ici sur probablement
est-ce que tu pourrais apporter un petit
peu ton parcours professionnels à votre
conseiller puisqu'avec un doctorat en
sciences de l'environnement c'est alors
je pense que on en parlera aussi si on
parle un peu de ce qui m'a amené
justement à faire cette chaîne youtube
met donc moi enfin voila j'ai fait un
collège lycée et en fait j'ai failli
partir en école de théâtre
j'avais une grosse passion pour le
théâtre ce qui est déjà très drôle ouais
j'ai fait beaucoup de théâtre quand
j'étais plus jeune et est en fait banon
je suis pas parti en école de théâtre
suis parti en prépa donc moi j'ai fait
une prépa physique-chimie laquelle j'ai
fais ta tête tu as vraiment hésité entre
les deux bah disons que j'ai été
fortement poussé à faire est très bas
parce que j'avais des bons résultats etc
mais
mais j'étais vraiment intéressés par le
théâtre après le problème du théâtre
c'est que les débouchés sont quand même
relativement faibles donc il y avait
aussi une île et de là il faut s'ajuster
un peu aux besoins et du coup je suis
parti je suis parti en prépa aussi parce
qu il ya un peu poussée est en prépa
alors je voulais des écoles assez bonne
donc je sais pas réussi du premier coup
j'ai fait des 5 devis moi j'ai fait 2e
2e année pour viser des meilleurs
concours et j'ai intégré le spcj paris
qui est une des grandes écoles
d'ingénieurs qui est pas très connue en
fait parce que c'est une petite promo on
était 80 je pense à mon époque
maintenant ça va peut-être un peu
augmenté enfin c'est au tour d'une
centaine et le s p s'est hissé une école
d'ingénieurs un peu particulière parce
que en fait elles touchent à toutes les
sciences enfin tout non c'est un grand
mot mais elle touche a vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de ses envies différentes donc
elle reste généraliste mais on touche
qu'à des sciences on a on a très très
peu de notions de management d'économie
et c est en fait elle est tellement
généralistes que normalement l'école
d'ingénieurs après la prépa 103 ans et
celle là il faut faire une quatrième
année de spécialisation situeront ton
diplôme de lait spécial parce que
justement il faut spécialisées qu'il
part pour pouvoir travailler pas mais
par contre ça donne vraiment une
connaissance générale de différentes
sciences donc on voit on voit un peu de
biologie on voit un peu de physiologie
et puis en physique en chimie ont
ratissé extrêmement large en cdi
traumatismes ont fait de la physique
quantique
on fait de la thermo ont fait
l'électricité ont fait l'optique aux
parents on voit vraiment beaucoup de
sens différente et après la prépa et
l'école d'angers en fait j'avais touché
vraiment à beaucoup de science et j'en
avais vraiment marre défiance en fait
mon école le respect c'est vraiment un
truc il ya la moitié des gens qui en
sortent un peu près qui font un doctorat
s'est orientée recherche et
développement dans le privé plutôt mais
c'est vraiment orienté là dessus et moi
c'était hors de question que je fasse un
doctorat et du coup je suis trop là bas
c'est drôle mais que les imbéciles qui
ne changent pas la ville voit aussi en
sortant d'école danger je voulais pas
faire de doctorat du tout bon c'est bien
et est du coup mon stage de fin d'études
je les fais dans les brevets donc
j'étais dans un cabinet de brûler je
passe tu vois ta tête tu es comme
einstein
ah je ne savais pas ça par successeur de
nstein la classe et et je devais faire
cette 4ème année d'où je leur ai dit et
ce que je fais ma quatrième et dernier
brevet et m'ont dit non c'est pas la
peine vaut mieux faire la formation en
continu et tu fais ta quatrième année où
tu veux et du coup j'ai fait de la
quatrième année j'ai fait une année
d'erasmus en norvège alors pour
plusieurs raisons déjà parce que je
voulais me couper un peu l'école en fait
j'ai fait beaucoup de clubs quand
j'étais à l'école j'ai repris le théâtre
j'ai écrit des pièces jeu former les
gens à l'impro puis ça me bouffe
énormément de temps donc je vais un peu
poupées et puis j'ai eu j'avais tout le
temps cette tentation en littéraire un
peu donc je voulais me laisser un peu de
temps au calme posé en norvège où il ya
personne pour essayer d'écrire un peu et
j'avais toujours été intéressés par
l'environnement mais je connaissais pas
grand chose donc en fait dans mon
erasmus j'ai choisi des coûts reliés à
la compréhension scientifique de
l'environnement
je pense qu'il aurait demandé à l'époque
je sais pas quelle est la probabilité
que l'homme soit responsable du
changement climatique je t'aurais
répondu 60% quoi mon niveau de mes
connaissances de ces sujets étaient
ouais bah j'ai été élevé dans une
famille où on verra peut être sur la
nature chez nous j'en ressors les
araignées plutôt que d'écraser mais les
vraiment je n'étais pas proche des
milieux écolo je n'étais pas proche de
ses milieux culturels et j'avais très
peu de connaissances est par contre un
des reproches que je peux faire à mon
école c'est que du coup ils se veulent
un inventeur d'avenir ont fait des gens
qui font de la recherche et
développement mais il y avait aucun
cours sur l'énergie aucun cours son
environnement ce qui fait j'en avais une
compréhension d'une culture extrêmement
limité c'est bon ça du coup c'est une
école très généraliste mais qui manquait
sa balle et c'est le cas de beaucoup une
école en france en fait ouais parce que
c'est des problématiques relativement
récente je pense je pense que à l'époque
les cours que j'ai fait en norvège
la majorité et n'avait pas d'équivalent
en france à ma connaissance que d'accord
cd c'est un master qui s'applique on
pourrait traduire par l'écologie
industrielle quelque chose à dire sur
l'écologie est en fait c'était voilà une
approche générale sur comment considérer
l'environnement alors moi j'ai fait
qu'une année donc j'ai pioché un peu des
trucs là dedans et là je me suis rendu
compte en fait que toi moi et voilà je
suis vraiment arriver dans
l'environnement par la compréhension
scientifique et je me suis rendu compte
qu'on avait quand même des gros ce qui
est à l'époque ma façon de contribuer à
sa entre guillemets mais ma
responsabilité que je me trouvais
c'était que j'avais été formé par mon
école mois l'école d'angers et la prépa
est aussi essentiellement gratuit
quelque part la société investit dans
toi et j'avais cette compréhension là je
pouvais faire de la recherche donc une
façon de rendre tout ça c'était de faire
un doctorat dans les sciences de
l'environnement et du coup alors moi
j'ai fait enfin je sais pas si c'est
utile de parler en paiement dr ça c'est
marrant comment je l'avais d'ailleurs
parce que j'avais postulé à une thèse
dans le sud de la france sur des procès
dans les stations d'épuration etc
et en fait j'ai jamais faite génie des
procédés pour ma scolarité donc j'ai été
refusé pour ça et sur le même le même
appel à projets il avait une autre thèse
donc si tu es mon cv a été
automatiquement passer sur cette thèse
et c'est celle que j
sans même directement possible enfin il
y avait d'autres gens évidemment mais on
doit aussi ajuster suis et je les fais
en fait j'étais attaché à l'université
de cergy-pontoise donc une heure de
paris mais l'essentiel du temps
j'étais au luxembourg en fait je
travaillais dans un structure privée pas
universitaire donc qu'ils n'avaient pas
la possibilité de fournir un doctorat
donc j'étais attaché à l'unité mais
l'essentiel du temps j'étais au
luxembourg est ok et je travaillais ma
tête c'était dans l'analyse du cycle de
vie c'est une méthode pour comptabiliser
tous les impacts environnementaux d'un
produit pour en parler un peu si ça
t'intéresse un peu après et ray cette
méthode elle se lie stick elle veut tout
prendre en compte tous les impacts
environnementaux n'est pas juste le
changement climatique ou et du coup il
ya quelques trucs qui sont compliqués à
rentrer là dedans pour pour des raisons
méthodologiques à cause des
approximations de cette méthode impose
et en particulier moi je devais intégrés
dans ceux d'entrée work là dans ce cadre
dans cette méthode l'impact du bruit du
trafic routier sur la santé humaine
naturelle question en tout cas très
précis qui est qu'ils aient un impact
assez important et vu que c'est une
méthode qui essaye d'évaluer les impacts
des produits et qui essaie de les
comparer entre eux et bien si tu ne
prends pas en compte tous les impacts tu
peux faire des mauvaises comparaison les
mauvais choix derrière donc l'idée c'est
vraiment de tout intégrer le mieux
possible et donc moi j'ai essayé
d'apporter ma petite pièce à l'édifice
sur ce truc là du coup tu utilises
joueurs pour certains produits quel est
l'impact que ça sur le bruit qui est
générée par les véhicules qui est
l'impact sur la santé des gens c'est ça
ben c'est plutôt qu'en fait c'est une
méthode qui va regarder alors tu peux le
faire pour un service tu peux le faire
pour une huile etc
mais le plus simple c'est de considérer
pour un produit donc je vais regarder ce
n'est pas l'ordinateur qu'on a dans
notre âme dans là devant nous et en fait
pourquoi le cycle de vie parce qu'on va
regarder de l'extraction des matières
premières jusqu'à la fin de vie que ce
soit je sais pas si mes réenterrés
recyclés et cet ordinateur il a eu
besoin de matières premières qu on est
allé mines et il a eu besoin d'une usine
etc
donc on va aussi regarder tous les
impacts d'origine la construction la
consommation et si louise windsor cent
mille ordinateurs et bien pourtant
ordinateur je vais être alloué 1 cent
millième de l'impact de ce studio est en
fait ton ordinateur il a besoin d'être
transportée aussi jusqu'à pour arriver
jusque chez toi et puis même tous ces
composants ont besoin les transporter
donc en fait comme quand tu fais cette
comptabilité
en gros c c'est un ensemble de procédés
c'est une espèce de chaînes de procéder
et tu fais tout cette comptabilité et ça
à la faim tue le tue le traduit en un
espèce d'énorme tableau qui fait
plusieurs milliers digne de tous les
échanges qui a eu pour ce produit de
l'environnement vers la société donc ce
qu'on a retirés comme une réelle ce
qu'ont appris que comme l'énergie etc et
de la société vers l'environnement
donc ce qu'on avait mis comme co2 comme
comme je sais pas particules fines pour
tes transports
tu as tous les flux en fait entre entre
la société l'environnement dans les deux
sens et du coup moi dans mon cas tu vois
bien que sur chaque produit il ya
toujours du transport enfin c'est rare
que tu es un produit où il ya jamais de
transport et ce transport
il va exposer des gens aux alentours à
de la pollution de l'air évidemment qui
est pris en compte mais également à du
bruit qui a un impact sur la santé
donc en fait même quand tu compares 2
ordinateurs en trop entre peut tout
aurait cet impact là est d'ailleurs en
acv on comptabilise l'impact sur la
santé avec une unité que tu as l'air de
connaître le dali parce que j'étais
encore ni en parler dans une autre tu
peux expliquer ce que ça lui va en fait
l'idée générale et c'est assez
intéressant pour le pour le bruit en
particulier mais les idées générales
c'est voilà comment on compare
différents impacts entre eux comment on
compare je sais pas quelqu'un qui perd
une jambe
quelqu'un qui est gêné quelqu'un qui
meurt cinq ans plus tôt etc et avec ça
on utilise le dali donc l'idée c'est que
on a une espérance de vie de référence
et si on meurt 5 6 ans avant ça fait
cinq ou six dalli donc ça c'est des
morts prématurées
mais après on peut aussi vivre avec un
handicap avec un handicap plus ou moins
graves
et à ce moment là si je vis dix ans avec
une jambe en moins
il ya des facteurs qui sont alloués à ça
qu'ils sont entre zéro et 1 donc plus
proche du 1 c'est que proche d'une année
entière perdu donc c'est grave et plus
proche des 0 c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas très grave
et du coup si je vis d'israël et une
jambe en moins on va dire que c'est 0-1
donc ça fait un dali et ça permet de
comparer des impacts sur la qualité de
vie
ou avec des impacts vraiment en perte
d'année et la logique pour le bruit voit
même un peu plus loin c'est de dire que
alors comment je schématise et ça en
fait c'est à dire par exemple si faire
le script pour une vidéo ça me prend 50
heures dans un environnement bruyant au
lieu de 40 dans un environnement calme
et bien j'ai perdu le viseur de ma vie
ok et du coup il ya des études surtout
tous âges
du coup je me dis c'est pas toi qui es
tu as fait non les effets mais en fait
moi au final moi je modélise pas du tout
le lien entre le bruit et la santé sas
et des études d d'épidémio c'est des
choses qui me dépassent un peu et ils
viennent avec des courbes qui relie en
gros un niveau sonore à un certain
nombre de dali est en fête et moi je
m'empare de cette littérature qui
existent en calcul des années de vie
perdues à cause du bruit un peu partout
dans le monde et j'essaye de l'intégrer
dans le cadre de l'analyse du cycle de
vie moi je je ne sais que d'intégrer ce
que c'est un cas qui posent des
problèmes en fait on a une approche un
peu statistiques donc ces moyennes dans
le temps et dans l'espace pour beaucoup
d'impact ya des choses c'est pas grave
tu vois qu'on émet du co2 ici ou en
chine en fait ça a pas beaucoup d'effets
parce que ça ça se mélange très
rapidement l'atmosphère par contre qu'il
ya un bruit devant chez moi ou en chine
ça change pas ça change tout pour moi et
vu que le bruit c'est quelque chose de
très localisés dans le temps et dans
l'espace
c'est un peu la limite de ce cadre là et
donc tu peux avoir des approches
évidemment tutelle des approches moyenne
ces approches statistiques mais même sur
l'épidémie au tout le monde n'est pas
individuellement n'est pas n'est pas la
même sensibilité au bruit et du coup tu
tues contourne un peu ces pratiques là
avec des approches statistiques donc en
fait en regardant le la situation d'être
d'assez loin
ok c'est marrant je n'ai pas cassé ses
croquis et et un champ de recherche sur
ces questions est ce qu'elle est 10
trucs qui sont surprenantes qui l'ont
surpris papa tu es si tu es ce que tu as
découvert c'était ouais parce que en
fait en fait la difficulté un peu de
tout ça c'est que
c'est quand même des domaines avec pas
mal d'incertitudes
enfin typiquement l'institut le le dali
associés à des émissions sonores s'est
jamais quelque chose que tu pourra
mesurer
donc tu es obligé de reposer sur des
modèles qui pose tout un tas de soucis
et est en fait qu quand j'ai appliqué
tout ça dans ma thèse je me rends compte
que l'impact sur la santé du transport
pourrait considérablement augmenter si
on y ajoutait le bruit en fait le bruit
deviendrait une cause majeure de
l'impact sanitaire du transport et ça
c'est assez surprenant c'était quelque
chose d'intuitif après je pense pas que
l'intégration que j'ai faite soit fautif
parce que j'ai essayé de vérifier par un
truc et c'est donc je suis relativement
confiant mais il peut y avoir des
problèmes dans la modélisation avant je
sais pas le travail des épées des bio et
surtout dans le dali il ya quand même la
subjectivité et en particulier les
personnes qui sont gênés on associe donc
cesser ces poids que je disais entre 0
et 1 si tu touches un peu à ça qu'ils
sont des jugements d'experts donc c'est
pas basé sur rien c'est basé sur des
rangs senti sur des comparaisons entre
différents problèmes mais si tu touches
un peu à ça tu change radicalement un
résultat sans avoir changé le reste de
la modélisation et et après même jeu
repose sur des modèles
d'acoustique en fait qui gère la
propagation enfin l'émission de la
propagation du bruit et même ça c'est
c'est assez difficile donc donc j'ai les
résultats intéressants mais il ya quand
même de grosses incertitudes qui y sont
associés c'est tout ça c'est quoi les
produits les plus polluants
ta peau du sceau d'or alors moi je
regardais je regardais le transport
routier
c'est vraiment le transport routier qui
domine tout bien là dans l'avion et le
train mais je pense c'est quelque chose
qu'on on a tous conscience et après
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de plus
en fait notre perception du bruit est
logarithmique tu vois qu'il ya deux
voitures s'est tu sais pas deux fois
plus fort qu'une voiture ce qui fait que
d'un point de vue global tu ministre
l'impact type tu concentre la
circulation y en a déjà tué parce que si
tu ajoutes et beaucoup de circulation en
droit il ya déjà beaucoup de circulation
le bruit ressenti va pas énormément
augmenté alors que si tu diffuses à un
peu partout balata les impacts
sanitaires plus plus important donc ça
peut aider
il ya des gens qui es tu dis ça par
exemple qui regarde voilà comment on
construit une nouvelle route au comment
on essaie de répartir le trafic pour
essayer de limiter cet impact sanitaire
et le fait que ça soit logarithmique ça
donne des résultats qui sont par
intuitif en fait le log ça perturbe
beaucoup notre intuition franc
intéressant et donc ça c'est la thèse et
après test a lancé sa chaîne youtube
pendant total ouais alors j'ai lancé mme
afrique du sud pendant ma thèse c'est ce
qui m'a permis de tenir ma thèse c'est
marrant parce que j'écoutais abrika sur
ton truc et il disait pareil qu'il a
lancé sa chaîne youtube pour tenir un an
quand il était frais leur mais non moi
je
en fait
alors ça a été deux choses un peu
différentes alors déjà pas en tant que
je faisais mes études en landaise j'ai
commencé à faire des recherches sur
internet
peut-être que la situation a un peu
changé parce que là je parle de quelque
chose qui a je sais pas si six ans par
là une des sept ans mais à l'époque
quand je tape et saufs
youtube typiquement changement
climatique y avait que des documentaires
que de la désinformation pure et dure et
en anglophone et sur le web c'est un peu
équilibré en francophone je trouve quand
on beaucoup plus facilement sur de la
désinformation et donc j'avais déjà
c'est conscience que ça serait bien
d'apporter un peu un pendant à ce qui se
raconte et de mauvais et puis après au
fur et à mesure que j'ai fait mon
doctorale j'ai continué à me renseigner
personnellement sur toutes ces questions
liées à l'environnement et je me suis
rendu compte que le problème n'était pas
nécessairement notre compréhension
scientifique le changement climatique
on sait ce qu'il cause on sait ce qu'on
devrait faire est en fait les
changements sont plutôt socio-économique
politique voie technologique phare ça
fait partie du problème mais mais on
sait déjà beaucoup de choses en fait là
dessus et et c'est juste qu'on fait
parce qu'on ce qu'on devrait faire c'est
un peu je ne sais pas comment dire enfin
c'est assez extraordinaire quand on y
pense qu'aujourd'hui on soit devenu
l'humanité se donne une force capable de
modifier le climat
c'est quand même incroyable qu'on y
pense c'est assez incroyable qu'on
arrive à le comprendre parce que c'est
des choses qui sont assez complexes et
pas quelque chose qu'on ressent quand on
sort de chez soi et le problème qu'on a
c'est que cette compréhension et bien
aujourd'hui on n'en tire pas encore les
conclusions je pense en terme en termes
d'actions ou en terme de jeu c'est pas
comment dire ingénierie sociale de
police et du coup voilà si si je
continue de croire que ma responsabilité
c'est un peu d'agir sur ces questions
parce que je les comprends et qu'il ya
plein de choses à faire
eh bien j'avais l'impression d'avoir
plus de poids en expliquant ces
problèmes que en faisant de la recherche
dans mon coin en plus j'étais assez
isolé en tant que des arts pour pas mal
de raisons déjà parce qu'en fait mon
sujet de recherche est hyper étroit et
du coup il y avait personne qui
recherchait la même question comment en
même temps que moi donc ça c'est un peu
particulier je pense j'avais personnes
avec qui vraiment discuté de ce que je
faisais quoi et même dans ta boîte là où
tu travailles et bah j'avais si j'avais
mon encadrants qui mettait un peu et
c'est pas toujours disponibles mais il
m'aider au maximum j'avais un autre
doctorant qui avait les mêmes problèmes
généraux que moi parce qu'il essayait
d'ajouter quelque chose dans
l'analytique de vie mais lui il essaie
d'ajouter les services écosystémiques
donc tu vois on avait les mêmes
problèmes avec la structure avec le
modèle de l'analyse du cycle de vie mais
notre objet d'étude n'était pas du tout
même donc vraiment sûr sur le bruit dans
la cvg que j'étais un peu tout seul
c'était pas évident de faire un jury de
thèse et est donc voilà je me sentais un
peu isolé j'avais l'impression que
j'aurais plus de poids en expliquant
tout ça sur youtube puis le truc aussi
c'est que je me suis pris un énorme choc
culturel moi parce que je suis arrivé de
norvège où ils ont la compréhension de
l'environnement je sais pas l'amour de
l'environnement le respect de
l'environnement dans leur culture
c'est en fait c'est un pays qui est
extrêmement riche la norvège est
d'ailleurs une partie des richesses se
fait sur un fond pétroliers ce qui est
assez logique mais mais le week-end ce
qu'ils font c'est qu'ils vont dans les
cabines à la montagne il n'y a pas
d'électricité et d'eau courante et ils
ont ils ont ils ont vraiment un rapport
à la nature qui est différent de chez
nous et je suis arrivé au luxembourg le
luxembourg c'est le pays où il ya le
plus il ya plus de voitures que de
permis de conduire tu discutes avec un
mec qui faisait un écovillage la la il
lisait un écoquartier il disait si je
vends moins de trois places de parking
par appartement je peux pas l'éventuel
c'est un défi on fait l'empreinte
écologique et la plus grande surtout
parce que c'est dire la richesse et qui
sont ils sont riches mais du coup
c'était vraiment un choc culturel je
suis arrivé dans un dans un service où
qu'ils disaient
de la cedh et de l'analyse chic de vie
pendant ces je vais dire je pense à rien
et il y avait des gens là dedans qui qui
ne comprenaient pas les enjeux ou qu'ils
avaient à ne rien à faire il y avait un
climato sceptiques par exemple et ça a
été assez déstabilisant qu est ce qui
fait que après ça s'est un peu arrangé
les années suivantes parce qu'il ya des
gens un peu plus jeunes qui sont arrivés
avec lesquels c'était plus facile de
discuter mais j'étais quand même dans un
environnement de travail qui était assez
difficile pour moi en plus j'ai tendance
à parler de tout ça quand les gens qui
racontent n'importe quoi j'ai tendance à
leur dire que et ça faisait des
situations parfois un peu conflictuelle
et donc voilà j'étais un peu tout seul
dans mon coin j'ai l'impression de
servir à rien j'étais entouré de gens
avec lesquels j'avais un peu mal
et du coup je
la chaîne ça a été aussi un refuge même
si ça prend une entente en doctorat une
chaîne en même temps je pense que tu
connais mes mais ouais c'était c'était
assez épuisant
et puis petit hasard aussi qu'il a joué
sur le fait que j'ai pas mal de temps
c'est que en fait ma compagne m'a
rejoint luxembourg mais là pas trouvé de
boulot dans les environs du coup elle
s'est retrouvée assez loin de se trouver
à anvers en belgique et du coup on était
séparés à la semaine d'ailleurs c'est
surtout elle qui faisait les verts tour
donc merci et bravo parce que c'est vrai
que porter la charge de sa faut l'avouer
mais du coup ma semaine page avec
j'avais forcément beaucoup plus de temps
libre quoi je me mange élite c'est un
truc et puis c'était doctorat chaîne
youtube est pire que les jeux vidéo mais
mes doctorat chaîne youtube c'était
quand même une bonne partie de mon temps
après mon un cadre a été pas mal
compréhensif aussi ce qui fait que
pendant ma tête j'étais assez souple
parce qu'en fait le point des problèmes
que j'avais c'est que c'est que je
reposait sur des modélisations qui était
assez longue
donc en fait j'ai jonglé pendant ma
thèse entre les moments où je ramenais
beaucoup de travail de doctorat chez moi
et des moments où je bossais un peu les
scripts au boulot quand j'avais les
périodes de creux pour des raisons
techniques
j'attendais les données soient
j'attendais des simulations j'ai aussi
une certaine flexibilité qui m'a permis
de l'abattre pas mal de travail quand
même sur cette période
mais c'est pas un rythme que j'aurais
tenu tout le temps et du coup après la
thèse alors j'ai fait j'ai soutenu en
trois ans après j'ai eu six mois de
prolongation je sais pas comment dire un
espèce de mini post-docs si tu veux j'ai
continué un peu mais traoré après ma
thèse et après je me suis lancée sur ma
chaîne à plein temps
donc ça fait un peu plus d'un an et puis
on écoute j'ai dansé le tpiy il ya un an
donc le financement participatif il ya
normal y'a pas un oeil à fin juillet
donc il ya eu neuf mois tendre et ça
marche bien je suis là je suis à mille
cinq cents euros je crois ce mois ci
s'effectue un peu d'un mois sur l'autre
mais maintenant je suis tout le temps au
dessus de 1000 je pense que en euros par
abonné je dois être assez haut sur
typique
communauté qui me soutient
incroyablement ce que je suis
relativement petit quand même par
rapport à toi ou monsieur fillon rica
j'ai quarante mille abonnés choix et du
coup j'ai pas mal de soutiens
et puis en ce moment j'essaie de
diversifier un peu mes activités j'ai
fait ma première conférence il ya pas
longtemps j'ai attendu quatre ans de
chaîne youtube pour qu'avant de faire ma
première conférence il ya eu cette école
alors c'était une conférence à grenoble
sur les impacts du changement climatique
quarante cinq minutes c'est très large
pour 45 minutes comme question on va
dire monde et les crises ont été
correctement ça oblige ça fait un peu
listings j'ai essayé de leur donner un
peu ma vision des choses et des
conclusions et cetera sur cette question
qui est pas toujours facile à apprendre
et c'était intéressant
la salle était remplie c'était de se
remplir une canne personnes chance non
c'est pas mal c'était la première c'est
pareil c'est un peu de boulot de
préparer une je pense quand ça fait
plusieurs ça va mais la première ferrari
style très difficile après turin cycle
moi j'avais gdg beaucoup plus de cela il
a recyclé
pas mal pas mal plus je suis vachement
dit dans mon jeu puis suite des slides à
droite à gauche mais je suis rarement
satisfait parce que je trouve donc je
refais 13-0 est assez souvent et voilà
donc si j'ai bien compris en fait c'est
ton intérêt pour l'écologie c'est fin
c'est vrai on est quand tu étais en
norvège ou bas j'ai toujours j'ai
toujours un peu une fascination pour la
nature j'aime bien les petites
sauterelles des trucs comme ça mais ma
compréhension de l'environnement est
vraiment née en norvège mais l'est elle
vraiment d'une approche scientifique
environnement et qu'on a des problèmes
ce qui est à mon avis à peu près des
gays enfin à peu près comment ça pas
tellement un rapport avec tant d'amour
ou non de la nature a priori en fait on
a un problème même d'un point de vue
purement logique ou utilitariste où je
sais pas comment dire qu'on aime ou pas
les petites bêtes
on a ce problème mais ce qui est des
événements marquants qui t'ont fait
c'est à dire en fait c'est vraiment
important non ça c'est toujours une
question qui revient et je dois être un
des rares à répondre non parce que je le
connais plein de gens et je pose cette
question autour de moi et il ya plein de
gens qui me disent je sais pas c'est en
voyant mourir un chat sur le bord de
plage et exagère mais il n'arrive
vraiment à mettre une date cette année
là on a parlé de chez pas du jour de
dépassement ça tombait le jour de mon
anniversaire enfin tu vois ils ont ils
ont un déclic
ou alors j'ai lu tel livre moi pas du
tout mais c'est aussi parce que je suis
rentré ce par les sciences donc c gepa
tu lis des études c'est une
compréhension voilà j'ai eu droit
oui le changement cpc continûment mais
je pense que je suis une exception là
dessus je sais pas ça serait intéressant
de savoir un peu plus ce qu'est ce qui
fait que les gens donnent de
l'importance à l'écologie et mènera pas
que ce soit plus progressive que ce
qu'on a toujours son intense a raconté
un peu plus ces trucs marquant que
d'accord mais moi mais quand on part moi
j'ai essayé d'en parler un peu autour de
moi des gens qui sont intéressés par ces
questions alors il ya des gens qui sont
élevés dans dont les familles sont déjà
sensibilisés à ça mais souvent il ya des
gens qui ont un déclic avec certains
certains livres ou avec ouais je sais
pas c est d actualité
peut-être non moi ça a été ça a été
continu et j'allais dire c'est un
processus en cours même de continuer à
comprendre les enjeux au fur et à mesure
mais la majorité du chemin je les fais
en norvège et peut-être dans ma première
année de doctorat et ça sert accompagné
aussi je pense de mes premières
réflexions économiques et politiques je
pense que j'en avais très peu avant en
fait ce qui l'a entraîné un peu l'autre
si tu commences à te poser les questions
des problèmes environnementaux du
commence à regarder un peu
l'économie ce qui se passe et comment
elle te bouger ou la politique ce qui se
passe et comment elle peut bouger et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que les
premières vidéos sur ma chaîne qui sont
pas les meilleures s'il y en a qui le
découvrent par ici ne commençait pas
forcément parler fois hier c'est sur le
capitalisme et c'est une série qui
serait peut-être que je refasse un peu
aux propres mains donc j'ai mature et et
que je fais des vidéos plus longue et un
peu plus poussé mais oui j'ai commencé
par là parce que l'idée générale c'était
de de parler un peu d'économie
d'expliquer les contraintes
environnementales et après de voir ce
que ça implique et pour l'économie
maintenant quand je vois ce que je
prends quand je sais parfaitement de
quoi je parle donc sur le changement
climatique
je sais pas si j'oserais parler de
l'économie où je suis quand même
beaucoup moins experts vous pouvez
travailler plus sur ça mais bon on
pouvait faire un don vous pouvez faire
un coup de vidéastes avec eureka est
alors on le fait de temps en temps on
discute de ça j'essaie de le couvrir un
peu sur la partie environnement il met
sur la partie économique
je vais faire une interview ya pas
longtemps que j'avais envoyé le texte
vous raconter des trucs sur l'économie
est ce que tu vas lui dire au chef parce
que s'ouvre un peu mes arrières mais
wayne dans l'idée c'était vraiment ça au
début de la chaîne en fait l'émission
est simple et mise au point est ce que
je fais dans mon île anagramme fall est
l'abréviation ça faisait m ap tu as donc
maps et je voulais faire une espèce de
cartographie en partant de l'économie
regardez toutes les contraintes qui
s'appliquent sur l'économie et réfléchir
à ce que ça implique pour nous
aujourd'hui si je me suis égaré en
chemin
tout est trop long mais mais comme toi
d'ailleurs je fais quand même des séries
sur une thématique et on n'est pas si
nombreux sur youtube france à faire ça
ouais je pense que ça vaille et là
plusieurs thèmes qui se met à faire des
séries parce que au début où je vois un
petit îlot enfin monsieur fils cadet des
petites séries à gauche à droite
oreca aussi a fait des séries ah oui
c'est vrai qu'en sur la crise de l'euro
les volumes de lieux de l'euro et ouais
je pense je pense que c'est une danse
geos tribouilloy rossi qui a fait des
séries sur la diabline heures et tout ça
qu'ils réfléchissaient l'essentiel et
truculent qui ont plus d'impact qis
qu'il a faim il disait que les plus doux
qui est étriqué avait plus un pacte qui
l'avait fait lui semblaient être les
séries qu'il avait fait le choix je
trouve ça intéressant c'est intéressant
c'est vrai et georges tu peux prendre tt
et étaient différentes séries pour ceux
qui alors j'ai commencé un tout petit
peu par le capitalisme surtout parce que
j'avais l'impression à l'époque que part
j'ai toujours l'impression que les gens
qui en parlent associe des définitions
différentes et des notions différentes
et en fait souvent ils s'engueulent en
parlant pas de la même chose ça c'est un
problème que j'ai dans les milieux même
militant écolo et tout ce qu'ils
désignent du doigt quand il critique le
capitalisme et considère que c'est le le
problème principal
et après ça m'a quand même permis de
faire j'ai fait quelques vidéos sur la
méritocratie il y avait un peu des
notions de politique et de philosophie
peut-être mais moins c'est hyper l'asic
en parle parce que tu as fais toi ou
monsieur fille je suis tout jeune en
plus à l'époque c'est rigolo de les
regarder maintenant c'est difficile de
se regarder surtout pour des seniors je
regardais et sur les premières vidéos
ouais c'est pas seulement les fous et
donc ça c'était la première après j'en
ai fait une sur le changement climatique
donc pas mal de vidéos différentes sur
les causes naturelles sur les causes
humaines une vidéo chez pas sur la ba
bordeaux et les nuages et c'est donc
vraiment les voilà les cause du
changement climatique et essaie
d'expliquer un peu les mécanismes
physiques à l'oeuvre notamment je pense
le bilan radiatif qui est hyper
important donc c'est le bilan entre le
rayonnement entrants et sortants sur
terre donc l'homme
pourquoi il fait 15 degrés un peu
comprendre les grands mécanismes du
climat sans même parler du changement
climatique je pense que c'est important
voilà compréhension du changement
climatique ensuite j'en ai fait sur les
conséquences j'en ai fait je crois en
france dans le monde j'ai parlé de
l'acidification des océans qui n'est pas
vraiment une conséquence du changement
climatique mais qui est une conséquence
directe des émissions de co2 donc qui
est quand même très liés donc j'ai une
sur les conséquences après j'ai fait une
série sur les d'autres formes de
pollution parce que le changement
climatique on peut considérer que c'est
une pollution
d'autres formes de pollution donc
pollution plastique le trou dans la
couche d'ozone qui est souvent le grand
exemple de voilà où on peut faire
quelque chose pour ces problèmes
environnementaux
l'eutrophisation qui est un mot qu'on
n'entend pas assez accès un gros
problème environnemental
donc ça c'est quand il ya trop d'azoté
de phosphore en gros et qu'on a ce
développement d'algues qu'on voit
d'ailleurs très bien même qu'en ce mois
la compagnie et problème c'est que ces
algues bas en pourrissant elle retire
l'oxygène du milieu et ça peut faire des
zones mortes en fait
et du coup là dedans il les
cyanobactéries des bactéries aérobies
qui se développe et qui s'est créé des
toxines et il ya plus beaucoup de vie
qui peut retourner donc c'est un vrai
problème pour les écosystèmes d'eau
douce est un vrai problème qu'on
constate sur les côtes aussi et parfois
un peu dans l'océan il ya des zones
mortes surtout les les océans fermer la
mer du nord par exemple t'as juste un
petit passage entre le danemark et la
suède ce qui fait que c'est relativement
clos alors qu'elle prend plein de
d'effluents agricoles de toute l'europe
autour et ça fait des phénomènes un peu
de zones mortes notamment sa fédé blue
mallegol donc plein d'algues tous les
six mois je crois et ça peut se voir de
l'espace en fait ça fait des énormes
tourbillon de lancer les toutes petites
dalles lcd même des
des cyanobactéries aussi mais tu vois
des grands vortex de l'espace est hyper
impressionnant
donc ça c'était sur les pollutions après
j'ai fait une série sur l'épuisement des
ressources
le pic pétrolier en particulier qui est
beaucoup plus je pense qu'il reste une
notion assez central le phosphore
d'ailleurs celle là si je devais refaire
ça changeait un peu je pense parce
qu'une réévaluation à la hausse du stock
géologique et je sais puisque j'avais il
est les métaux alors ce qui s'épuise et
des minerais et concentrés et fax et
facilement accessible parce qu'on l'ait
transmis pas les métaux il reste autant
de faire sur terre que vos delluc en
gros mais mes skis ski s'épuise ses
démineurs et qu'on peut facilement
accéder et qu'on peut facilement
transporté transformé pendant donc c'est
plus en plus difficile de de produire
des métaux utilisés par nos sociétés et
après j'ai fait une petite série sur des
abris des problèmes plus globaux genre
la biodiversité parce que c'est lié à
des pollutions si lee addy ressources
points c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
c'est un problème un peu à part je pense
l'anthropocène donc l'idée qu'on est
dans une rolls anthropocène c'est une
proposition d re géologique on n'est pas
dedans mais c'est l'idée conscrits dans
une ère géologique nouvelle parce que le
principal driver de l'évolution du
climat et la terre aujourd'hui c'est ce
sont les activités mais est en fait là
dessus je voulais poursuivre sur les
limites année terre ce qui une façon de
concevoir certaines limites et et ce
script je l'avais envoyé à mes électeurs
et mondiaux à nantes ut répète donc
passer à autre chose
et du coup il attend que choqué par et
je me suis lancé dans l'énergie qui est
un chantier incroyablement complexe et
j'aurais jamais adressé l'énergie
pendant que j'étais en test parce que
c'est un peu plus éloignés des
compétences que j'avais donc ça me
demande de beaucoup plus et me
documenter ce qui en fait alors pour le
coup mon école d'ingé c'est pas
forcément génial pour des gens qui sont
très spécialisés après parce qu'ils ont
une énorme culture scientifique qui leur
sert pas nécessairement mais pour moi
avoir touché un peu à tout la physique
c'est hyper utile pour le climat parce
que tu as les problèmes
d'électromagnétisme donc 2
flux rentrant que de lumière d'optique
de mécanique des flux de thermodynamique
cette touche un peu à tout les sciences
c'est du coup ça m'a vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup aidé d'avoir une connaissance
générale sur ces questions et maintenant
je suis sur l'énergie si depuis quelques
temps et j'ai fait aussi fureur vidéo de
critiques enfin l'analyse de discours
climato-sceptiques et ça ça je pense que
ça en fait je pense que pour les gens
qui ont une approche enfin on pourra en
parler parce que c'est une opinion qui
teintera peut-être mais mais en gros je
pense que les gens qui ont une
compréhension de ces enjeux non
seulement nous avait expliqué un peu les
tenants et les aboutissants et est ce
que ce qu'on sait l'état de nos
connaissances scientifiques qui est en
constante évolution mais on s'est quand
même un certain nombre de choses et en
même temps on doit aussi lutter contre
les gens qui racontent n'importe quoi
parce que tout le monde n'est pas
outillé pour au final
au final je pense même que comment dire
les vidéos général que j'ai fait sur la
compréhension du changement climatique
je pense qu'un certain nombre de
personnes pourrait les faire il ya
beaucoup de doc
il ya des choses qui sont pas si
technique que ça regardez les argument
des climato sceptiques c'est quelque
chose d'autrement plus complexe et
technique et ça je pense qu'il ya moins
de personnes qui peuvent le faire donc
du coup j'ai encore plus qu'une
impression que c'est la mission situé
aussi à moins de personnes qui peuvent
faire ça autant je me concentre où tu
peux te penses que c'est plusieurs de
déconstruire un argument qui est aux
sceptiques que de faire parler de
solaire thermique par exemple
ouais ouais ouais ouais parce que tu
rentres dans une vraie polémique tarifs
dans des champs où il ya une vraie des
informations
et d'ailleurs il ya des lobbys qui
finance cette désinformation
c'est même pas de la théorie du complot
il ya des preuves parce qu'il ya des
intérêts économiques énormes toute façon
le changement climatique se remet un peu
en cause notre utilisation de ressources
fossiles
ces 85 % de l'énergie utilisée par
l'humanité c'est absolument énorme c'est
les plus grosses multinationales au
monde c'est évident que l on a un
intérêt à ralentir les actions ou à
nuire un peu à la compréhension globale
de saison je alors que sur le solaire
thermique
il y a moins d information parce qu'il
ya moins d'intérêt à désinformer c'est
des sujets qui sont moins polémique et
puis et puis après même moralement c'est
pas pareil d'expliquer et puis de
rentrer dans un champ plus conflictuel
que c'est un peu conflictuelle d'aller
critiqué le discours de quelqu'un
d'autre
et du coup battu tu manges des
commentaires qui sont pas sympa tu sais
c'est pas pareil il faut être un peu aux
outils et la tue ouais mais je en termes
de compétences techniques je pense qu'il
y a besoin de plus de compréhension
technique du compétences techniques pour
déconstruire un argument qui mot c'est
le climato sceptiques
ouais parce que dans pas mal de tes
vidéos chocs fins km sur le
photovoltaïque par exemple c'est ouais
le photovoltaïque c'est vrai le
photovoltaïque c'est une des vidéos les
plus difficiles que j'ai fait et pour
une raison assez simple c'est que cette
technologie qui est voulu extrêmement
vite tu vois quand quand j'ai fait la
vidéo sur les éoliennes c'est quelque
chose qui est fiable maintenant qui est
relativement aboutie y aura pas de
pousser technologiques majeures et du
coup quand je lis des articles
scientifiques qui ont un ou deux ans qui
sont basées sur des données qui ont un
ou deux ans et c'est ben j'ai encore
quelque chose qui est crédible
aujourd'hui si je regarde aujourd'hui
des publications photos sur le
photovoltaïque
elles ont un temps elles sont basées sur
des données qui en ont un ou deux et en
fait ça c'est dû à dépasser quoi et ça
c'est extrêmement dur c'est que c'est un
domaine là aussi il ya des polémiques et
là aussi les enjeux économiques mais en
plus qui bougent très vite et j'ai la
chance enfin j'ai eu la chance de
j'avais quelqu'un de mon école de promo
sous moi qui fait une thèse dans ce
domaine là et qui m'a pas mal aidé en
expliquant ce qu'ils voyaient lui au
jour le jour tu as donc sinon je me
serais fait avoir par le par le décalage
temporel ça s'est même problème que pour
l'intelligence artificielle aussi c'est
demain qu'il va tellement vite que c'est
si on parle des derniers articles qui
ont sorti même ça j'ai présenté un truc
qui est ce que les troupes sol est dans
un an
c'est un petit peu embêtant non c'est
pas facile ces aspects là et du coup ça
dépend vraiment différent ça ça dépend
vraiment sur le sujet parce que tu
parles de l'hydroélectricité c'est quand
même quelque chose maintenant de solides
depuis des décennies donc tu as un peu
de recul mais tu parles de technologies
nouvelles c'est très très dur
et puis rose art il ya aussi tellement
d'intérêt économique il ya aussi
beaucoup de beaucoup de bullshit de soi
surtout dans le domaine des start up et
les gens qui vendent des choses
ouais et du coup ça comme ça au caire
comme une certaine compétence technique
pour essayer pour faire un jugement doit
être des bronzes approximatif bayésiens
cas et il ya un autre aspect aussi quand
on critique un discours qui fait que
c'est beaucoup plus dur à produire pour
moi je trouve parce que ça me prend
vraiment beaucoup de temps quand j'ai
fait les deux vidéos sur les dernières
la sueur françois gervais ça me prend
vraiment vraiment beaucoup de temps et
l'autre truc important c'est que en fait
c'est une vidéo qui va être à je sais
pas comment dire un lieu de conflits
culturels quoi un lieu d'opposition d
opinion parce qu'il va y avoir à la fois
des gens qui critiquent françois gervais
des gens qui sont convaincus par lui et
du coup ça fait que la vidéo faut
qu'elle soit
impeccable comme si je fais une erreur
sur le photovoltaïque sur l'éolien
amblas signal je la mets en commentaire
au pire je fais un errata dans la vidéo
d'après j'ai déjà fait un pour des
erreurs que j'ai trouvé grave c'est
parce c'est pas c'est ainsi c'est
important mais c'est rattrapable là tu
fais une erreur en critiquant le
discours de quelqu'un tu vas faire
tacler les gens qui sont à moitié
convaincue il vont rejeter la vidéo
direct et tout donc en fait il faut que
sur le fond elle soit impeccable et du
coup ça demande beaucoup plus de
vérification je vérifie tout trois
quatre fois je demande à les gens qui
touchent un peu leur leurs opinions
leurs sur différents sujets phares
opinions leurs connaissances sur
différents sujets de valider ce que je
pense ce que je dis ce que je pense que
ce que j'ai produit dans la vidéo est
d'ailleurs c'est encore plus compliqué
parce que c'est des scripts qui sont
illisibles donc en fait je fais une
version bêta de la vidéo pour le
renvoyer c'est ça aussi c'est beaucoup
plus de travail
j'ai juste d'envoyer inscrits ah oui
mais en même temps il ya tellement de
trucs techniques sur ces vidéos là alors
déjà il ya les bouts de vidéo qui met
donc en fait si les gens les voient pas
ils comprennent pas ce que tu dis après
et puis même c'est tellement basé sur ds
lite s'ils n'ont pas les slides ça va
pas donc il faudrait envoyer les slides
avec le script est tout autant en fait
ce que je fais c'est que je fais une vie
une vidéo alpha juste au micro tu vois
je m'emmerde pas le gêner et comme ça
ils ont le truc et ça sert de base de
travail et je pense que les la dernière
de gervais ya eu deux versions bêta
avant d'avoir une version alpha qui
avait pas encore modifié
d'ailleurs ça s'entend raté au micro
casque et le micro et sensible donc dès
que tu bouges un peu ça change
et tu l'entends que que le son est pas
toujours enregistrés à une condition
mais il ya franchement sur ces vidéos là
il doit y avoir 13 14 enregistrement
audio distance
des fois ça dépasse juste de deux trois
minutes mais c'est des vidéos qui sont
qui sont lisses et je savais comment
dire sap et son logo sont vachement mais
ça après mois sur youtube au début on n
y fait pas des vidéos aux hommes je suis
resté sur ce format là il ya un public
qui est content de ce que je produis il
y en a d'autres qui peuvent faire les
vidéos du plus vulgarisée je n'ai pas de
problème avec ça mais je pense qu'il ya
un public qui cherche des vies
ou un peu longue à carreaux beiges après
en avoir atterri aux élites monde et
youtube qui font des vidéos de moi 20
minutes dans ce podcast
mais il ya clairement un intérêt à voir
des vidéos plus longues heures et celle
du cas pour ce style de vidéos assez
technique
ça vaut le coup de prendre le temps de
bien poser les choses mais sinon tu
pense qu'en terme parce que j'ai
beaucoup de mal à me représenter la
taille du mouvement climato-sceptiques
et l'art est important qu'ils ont bercé
mes gens qui ont un impact énorme sur
nos sociétés parce que je pense qu'ils
sont pas si nombreux ceux qui organisent
ce discours mais par contre qu'il se
passe c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui y croient à presser s'est aussi
associée à des mouvements plus généraux
de défiance envers la science ou envers
les institutions etc
en fait les mouvements ce que j'essaye
de faire en ayant une approche
scientifique de l'environnement il
faudrait que je supporte et que je fasse
aussi du travail d'esprit critique
d'explication la méthode scientifique ou
des méthodes scientifiques etc
parce que ça participe en fait mais il
ya des gens qui me disent à eux mêmes
dans les commentaires et kankan leur
demande quand j'essaie de comprendre un
peu pourquoi ils sont les maths aux
sceptiques des personnes qui regardent
les vidéos ndis bas voilà on les a menti
je sais pas sur le médiator on a réagi
en retard sur l'amiante comment on peut
faire confiance aux institutions tu vois
et est en fait il jette le bébé avec
l'eau du bain
en quelque sorte quelle est la taille de
ce mouvement je pense qu'il ya quand
même encore une bonne partie de la
population qui remet en cause le fait
que l'origine soit humaine et puis après
je pense que la majorité n'a pas encore
tellement conscience des enjeux ou de ce
que ça peut représenter pour leur vie
mais c'est normal parce que c'est
extrêmement dure a pas se représenter
donc petit à petit on voit un
déplacement quand même au début les
climato sceptisme et enfin au début
30-40 ans expliqué qu'ils avaient pas de
réchauffement ensuite que le
réchauffement est pas humain et puis
maintenant ça glisse petit à petit
vers c'est peut-être eu marre mais c'est
pas grave c'est la nourriture des
plantes on aura un peu plus de verre sur
terre tu et il ya ce glissement et après
surtout ce qui se passe c'est que si à
une polémique dans le champ scientifique
qui n'a pas d'implication sur la société
c'est pas très grave il n'y a pas
tellement de gens qui vont s'emparer
d'un combat entre les maliens et les
fréquentes histoire ça les intéresse pas
tant que mais par contre si on commence
à utiliser le changement climatique pour
expliquer qu'il faut les menus et notre
consommation de ressources donc il faut
mettre une taxe
tu vois l'appareil par contre là on va
avoir beaucoup de gens pour qui comment
dire
au lieu que ce soit les éléments
scientifiques qui nous explique qu'on
doit consommer moins de ressources du
coup doivent mettre une taxe
ils vont dire ben non c'est parce qu'on
veut nous mettre une taxe qu'on a
inventé toute nature est en fait au fur
et à mesure qu'on va vouloir essayer de
pallier en partie aux problèmes
environnementaux
d'ailleurs il va garder ces petits corps
on peut par les climato sceptiques mais
même pour les problèmes environnementaux
en général il ya des gens qui vont dire
ça grave de perdre la biodiversité il ya
des gens qui vont dire y'a pas de pic
pétrolier enfin et ce scepticisme
elle va être d'autant plus il va être
d'autant plus là que les problèmes
environnementaux auront des impacts sur
la société et là là là moi je le vois
sur une vidéo il ya clairement une vague
supplémentaires depuis qu'on parle
beaucoup la taxe carbone c'est s'est du
coup c'est devenu un axe
j'ai pas comment dire en français une
escroquerie pour pour pour taxer les
gens et en plus c'est des gens souvent
pour qui une taxe est un espèce de trou
noir dans l'économie genre ça aval de
l'argent qui ressort nulle part c'est ça
c'est un truc que j'ai du mal à
comprendre mais les gens font pas
toujours le lien entre j'ai pas l'argent
qui sert à entretenir les routes où
l'argent qu'ils reçoivent et puis
l'argent qu'on leur prend acte et du
coup je pense que je pense que c'est des
combats en fait des combats il ya
peut-être des mots plus plus juste que
ça mais c'est des combats qui sont
jamais gagnés en fait qu'on peut jamais
considéré comme acquis il faut toujours
lutter contre ces discours là et c'est
vrai pour ça c'est vrai je sais pas pour
le droit à l'avortement voilà on s'est
dit maintenant là c'est tranquille et on
voit qu'ils commencent à être remis en
question à différents endroits
mais faut se rendre compte que c'est des
cons pas qu'il faut faire pour toujours
en fait faut maintenir un état c'est pas
des combats que tu fais une fois à une
fois que que celle là c'est fini après
pour le changement climatique au moins
les médias en ont un traitement qui
comprennent pas toujours tout il ya
quand même peu de grands journaux ou de
trucs qui remettent en cause changement
climatique anthropique
au final ils ont un meilleur traitement
du climat que du glyphosate des ogm du
nucléaire et toc dans un cas ils ont
quand même compris ce consensus
scientifique etc plus à la population
qu'il faut expliquer comment ça
fonctionne quels sont les enjeux pour
pourquoi on a confiance dans ce qu'on
sait et c'est je sais pas si c'est clair
ce que j'ai racontée ouais et du coup
une des questions que je pose c'est quel
poste va recevoir deux vidéos qui parce
que ça reste assez technique ce qu'est
ce que tu penses dans ces vidéos des
analyses
est-ce que ça convient vraiment ces gens
là alors ça c'est une bonne question
j'ai des retours en plus moi je passe
beaucoup de temps à répondre aux
commentaires chance beaucoup plus que
beaucoup de gens mais du coup j'ai j'ai
des retours alors en fait ça convainc
les gens que françois gervais mais dans
le doute s'est il est exposé d'arguments
il ya des gens qui sont un peu le cul
entre deux chaises ce qu' il n'y a pas
forcément en phase de bonne
vulgarisation de bonnes je pense les
conférences sur le climat font moins de
vue que les conférences le climato
sceptiques des conférences qui
expliquent le climat à mon avis faut
moins de vue que des conférences climato
sceptiques quand tu vois qu'il fait et
350 mille quatre cent mille vu c'est
quand même beaucoup
c'est quand même beaucoup et il ya des
gens du coup c'est ça les met dans le
doute et du coup ceux qui sont dans le
doute et bien ils sont rassurés par ma
vidéo ils sont convaincus par mes vidéos
des gens qui sont climato-sceptiques
initialement se servent plutôt de
françois gervais pour valider leurs a
priori et ces gens là sont son sens pas
forcément convainc câble ou alors il
faudrait comprendre pourquoi ils ont cet
a priori et d'ailleurs c'est quelque
chose que j'essaie de faire des
commentaires
et il ya des positions extrêmement
différente et des gens qui remettent en
cause toutes les institutions toute la
science et c'est donc comme on en a
parlé il ya des gens qui ont plutôt une
vision extrêmement libérale de
l'économie donc pour qui l'état ne doit
jamais intervenir ou presque pas et du
coup comme les problèmes
environnementaux justifierait une
intervention de l'état ou une
modification de la structure où
certaines régulations économiques
eh bien ils préfèrent nier ces éléments
là que d'accepter de revoir leur
position sur l'économie ça arrive il ya
des gens à l'autre extrémité entre
guillemets du spectre économique qui
considèrent que en fait nos pays
bénéficient des écarts de richesse dans
le monde donc que ya des pays en voie de
développement et pour qui le changement
climatique c'est une invention pour les
empêcher de se développer donc donc là
c'est pareil c'est en fait ils ont une
opinion politique a priori et du coup il
en tire une conclusion sur le changement
climatique
donc là que c'est une escroquerie et
après ils vont chercher des éléments
pour appuyer leurs a priori est située
la situe à leur retire des arguments
qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien soit ils
comprennent pas soit eni soit aloi au
millefeuille argumentatif donc en fait
ils vont te répondre avec d'autres
arguments et ça continue sans fin et et
après il est très surprenant aussi pour
moi yam
il ya une part non négligeable de
personnes âgées alors que je suis sur
youtube qui est en fait une voix c'est
bien parce que souvent ils utilisent
leur nom prénom dans les commentaires et
tu veut taper sur ie google et tu tombes
sur monsieur untel 75 ans est hélas il
ya un espèce de deux refus d'une forme
de responsabilité enfin pour eux ils ont
rendu le monde meilleur ils ont vu
considérablement s'améliorer et c'est
inconcevable que
on est gros problème avec
l'environnement il refuse ça pour eux
c'est une espèce de chez pas de
d'imaginaire de jeunes qui veulent leur
mettre une espèce de responsabilité
il ya aussi un peu une notion de
d'affrontements entre générations fin de
lettre d'opposition générationnelle sur
ouais je pratique ouais en fait il ya
beaucoup de tension sur cette question
du changement climatique qui vient de de
l'idée que qui est responsable turc à
qui on rejette la faute peut-être aussi
parce que ça joue sur à qui on va
demander de faire des efforts mais cette
responsabilité tout le monde ni sa part
et préfère pointer du doigt les autres
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on voit même
dans le discours politique c'est la
faute au gouvernement c'est la faute aux
grandes entreprises
c'est la faute aux riches s'ils ont
passé autant de temps à rejeter la faute
sur les autres cas agir on aurait déjà
fait un bon bout de chemin je pense
et du coup il ya des motivations très
différentes pour avoir un a priori
négatif sur son antenne
car moyens d'intérêt à déconstruire un
peu les mauvais argument des
climato-sceptiques influent clairement
et aussi un intérêt à mieux vulgariser
les raisons scientifiques pour laquelle
on enfin le changement climatique est
acceptée par la communauté scientifique
après il ya moi l'impression que j'ai
souvent sur ce genre de truc c'est qu'il
ya un gros effort également mais qui est
également très difficile à faire
peut-être que du tout c'est plus un jeu
d'attaqué sur ce créneau qui est juste
de perdre en fin d'année les gens à se
rendre compte qu'ils sont dans un
raisonnement motivés qui est copains ils
sont constamment en train de justifier
et qui sont prêts à du coup à prendre
n'importe quelle raison une dentition
qu'ils ont déjà au préalable et je sens
que le truc là on pourrait vraiment
réussir à gagner oui si on a les gens à
prendre un peu plus dur culture sur
pourquoi est ce qu'il pense sur ce
qu'ils pensent et sur le fait qu'ils
sont moins bien informés que que des
experts à elle mais je là je suis
d'accord et c'est extrêmement difficile
alors j'ai ça un dernier petit point
du coup cette vidéo je critique c'est
aussi une autre façon d'expliquer le
changement
tu peux appliquer ce qu'il est tu peux
expliquer ce qu'il n'est pas et je pense
que c'est assez intéressant comme
approche
je pense que enfin je pense que j'étais
a pris la tête j'ai compris la théorie
de l'évolution après ma scolarité et je
pense que j'aurais mieux compris si on a
expliqué que ça n'était pas en plus de
ce que c'était que que j'ai pu j'ai pas
comment dire mais que peut rester des
mutations aléatoires qui sont
sélectionnés par l'environnement et ce
n'est pas l'environnement qui les fait
apparaître et ben ça c'était pas très
clair dans ma tête quand j'étais au
lycée
et si on a expliqué ben pourquoi cela
marquise mais je crois que c'est ça que
j'appelle ça fonctionne pas eh ben ça
aurait été un bon complément
donc c'est complémentaire après je suis
vraiment d'accord avec toi mais mais
cette idée de de faire comprendre aux
gens leurs préjugés ou leurs a priori et
d'où ça vient et c'est je pense est
extrêmement extrêmement difficile ça
touche aussi à note y avait des études
qui a été fait là dessus et aux etats
unis c'est assez incroyable montré chez
les démocrates et les républicains leurs
convictions en un changement climatique
anthropique d'origine humaine en
fonction du niveau d'études plus un
démocrate et instruit plus ils croient
que c'est l'homme plus un républicain et
instruit - y croient que c'est l'homme
donc en fait au fur et à mesure de son
éducation
il arrive à trouver des justifications
pour se protéger pour des biais de
confirmation et du coup un important
pour lui c'est de rester alors cette
lésion très engagé froid politiquement
donc c'est de rester dans son groupe la
et au final avoir une opinion divergente
de son groupe ça lui coûterait
extrêmement cher socialement donc c'est
des choses qui coûtent beaucoup plus
cher que de nier l'évidence
en fait j'avais été pas mal je pense tu
l'as lu mais tu l'as lu sapiens et une
brève histoire l'humanité mais mais mais
l'idée c'est ça c'est que on est arrivé
jusque là
finalement grâce à notre capacité à
croire en des fictions presque plus
quand la réalité les religions les
systèmes politiques l'argent des choses
sur lesquelles
on s'accorde et aujourd'hui on a un
problème avec ces d'opinion et c'est
parce qu'on croit plus facilement des
fictions karité c'est donc c'est à la
fois un énorme avantage évolutif parce
que sinon on serait probablement pas là
et puis ça c'est aussi un frein à
certaines évolutions
ouais parce que sur ce que tu disais
tout au début sur le fait de parler des
arguments du côté opposé
pour mieux expliquer son idée il ya une
vidéo de veritas y sommes des deux
premières vidéos de veritas yomou fait
il parle de sa thèse dans sa thèse et a
travaillé sur comment rendre des vidéos
aussi instructif que possible et
justement ce qu'il disait c'est que si
on présente juste la bonne théorie juste
même avec les bons arguments même bien
expliqué en fait les gens vont pas
forcément prêté suffisamment attention
ils vont avoir un peu une écoute
superficiel et mais ils vont retenir
qu'on leur a appris quelque chose du
coup ils vont gagner confiance en eux
mêmes en confortant leur intuition
du coup ce que ce que disait d'un
veritas y sommes c'est que ce qui ce qui
est important de faire d'un point de vue
pédagogique c'est de te présenter
l'intuition naïve avant tout est de
montrer qu'elle est erroné l'accent sur
savez ce que tu disais ça me va
s'attaquer dans les bailleurs et c'est
un truc que j'essaie d'appliquer assez
régulièrement c'est possible que ces
deux add s'était tu travailles sur
l'intuition parce que parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de trucs en sciences qui sont
contre intuitive et on peut présenter
directement le truc contre intuitif et
les gens vont pas forcément être
interpellé
alors que si on insiste sur le fait que
c'est vraiment contre intuitif en
présentant d'abord l'intuition des mois
j'aurais parié que les semblerait que et
en fait non je pense que ça peut avoir
un effet plus important est quoi on se
la tête des vidéos font ça très très
bien il ya pas mal d'études qui montrent
aussi que quoi finalement les gens plus
intelligents sont également des gens qui
avant tout sont capables de justifier
quelques positions qu'ils se soient plus
rapidement aux soins sont des meilleurs
avocats en fait et que du coup c'est pas
étonnant que s'ils sont dans un
environnement social qui promeut telle
ou telle idée
et pour eux c'est important de faire à
part partie de cet environnement social
et ça c'est le cas de tout le monde a
tendance à vouloir se rapprocher de
certains environnements sociaux et de
justifier le fait que notre
environnement social et le bon sens et
du coup si on est plus intelligent on
est juste meilleur à rationaliser sa
justifier ça du coup si on prend pas
conscience du fait du raisonnement
motivés et des billets que ça poser des
problèmes que ça pose en gros ce que
sont en train d'essayer de dire c'est
que l'intelligence est vraiment pas
corrélé avec la capacité à penser
adéquatement un problème c'est assez
bizarre dit comme ça non mais je vois ce
que tu veux bien mais en fait pour
limiter ces billets il faudrait ne pas
avoir d'amis tout cas et donc à ce
mouvement qui s'appelle actrice mais
efficace qui je sens insiste beaucoup
sur le fait de s'entourer de gens qui
valorise le fait de bien réfléchir ou de
de biens prioriser d'avoir une réflexion
de prendre du recul de pas avoir de
raisonnement motivé de bien réfléchir
que et du coup je pense que c'est
extrêmement important de développer ce
genre de communauté donné les gens à se
donner des récompenses social sur le
fait d'avoir bien réfléchi d'avoir pris
du recul sur sa position d'avoir été
bienveillant de débattre bien mais ça
veut dire techniquement un valoriser le
fait que quelqu'un change la vie ou puis
changer la vie et puis valoriser le fait
de reconnaître ses erreurs
parce que qui sait ça revient au truc
contre intuitif lorsqu'on est capable de
reconnaître qu'on a fait une erreur
c'est qu'on n'a compris beaucoup plus
que quelqu'un qui a été acquis aller
directement vers la bonne réponse qui
donc la démarche qui consiste à passer
par l'erreur bafa c'est instructif bon
c'est pas bien de faire des erreurs mais
c'est pas grave d'en faire surtout si on
les reconnaît comme ça et si on est dans
un environnement social qui encourage
cherokee qui les trucs que j'ai c'est
dans corrélativement c'est le fait de
d'exprimer mais avec beaucoup de
modestie épistémique notre intuition
mais potentiellement ainsi se distancer
de notre intuition notre intuition c'est
pas forcément nous ça permet de mieux se
rendre compte des trucs qui sont contre
intuitif et des moments où du coup il
faut il faut abandonner un peu
d'intuition que ça se tient
du coup selon passer à d'autres
questions comment est-ce que tu
réfléchis tutut informe de façon
générale
bon à la fois sur l'environnement où les
autres sur l'actuelle alors comment je
réfléchis de façon générale ça a pas mal
changé depuis que je suis enfant je suis
plus en tête presque
avant je prenais le train tous les
matins en fait j'avais fait exprès de
choisir l'endroit où j'ai vite pour
pouvoir les au travail en train ce qui
fait que j'avais une bonne heure et
demie trains par jour et j'en profitais
pour lire courrier international donc un
un journal qui al'intérêt en fait d'être
un patchwork
ils prennent des articles partout et les
traduisent donc il ya toujours une
sélection dont il ya une espèce de ligne
éditoriale mais il essaie de la rendre
deux autres en mettant notamment des
articles de différentes opinions face à
face et c est donc l'intérêt c'est que
c'est un truc qui sortait toutes les
semaines donc ça permettait d'avoir déjà
un peu de recul par rapport à
l'information
et puis c'était une approche générale
avec pas mal d'opinions différentes je
trouvais ça intéressant à lire
et matin j'écoutais un peu france inter
aussi que je trouve pas trop mal pour
suivre l'actualité
maintenant j'avoue que je suis un peu à
la ramasse question informations
informations bon ça fait très longtemps
que j'ai pas j'ai plus d'antennes moi la
télé ça sert pour regarder du contenu
internet chez moi et du coup comment je
me tiens au courant de l'actualité
et bien honnêtement
je me tiens pas tant que ça l'actualité
est souvent j'ai des gens qui me gêne
beaucoup qui ne feront monter les
articles quand c'est lié à mon domaine
d'expertisé ou de messages et que je
traite mais après au final je fais peu
de vidéos sur l'actualité
j'en ai fait un petit peu sur des
questions politiques la taxe carbone en
particulier mais je fais peu de vidéos
sur l'actualité
je regarde quelques sites de
vulgarisation scientifique pour voir un
peu ce qui se dit sur le climat plutôt
des trucs en anglais j'aime bien carbon
brief qui a un blog tenu par des
scientifiques du climat qui sont
vraiment au taquet qui enfin dans
l'arctique sont extrêmement complet je
regarde un peu la peau climat j'avoue ça
c'est un sujet qui m'intéresse en soit
en fait c'est vraiment si j'échoue
facile et du coup je regarde un peu la
blogosphère scientifique anglophone
il ya quand même quelques sites de
référence qui sont ils sont pas mal et
voilà sinon un peu les fils facebook
twitter mais je passe beaucoup moins de
temps que toi je suis pas addict à ces
trucs là moi je suis plutôt addict aux
jeux vidéo c'est pas très bien mais je
suis là a dit affûteur hockey et quand
commence à voler ta réflexion autour de
l'écologie est ce que je peux au cours
des cinq dernières années il ya des
trucs ac était de plus en plus
d'importance ou al'inverse détruit
coûteuse moins en moins d'importance
ah bin là ça serait là ça serait
plusieurs heures de discussions en plus
c'est un sujet extrêmement vaste et
peut-être c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on
n'en parle pas tant que ça
scientifiquement non plus et que ça
c'est que sa demande de toucher à pas
mal de sujets différents et donc sa
touche vraiment o comment dire aurait
elle a des notions de stores d'évolution
des intempéries est tous des choses on a
beaucoup de données c'est difficile de
france et c'est pour ça que c'est très
large aussi sa touche a énormément
d'observation c'est pas comme une belle
formule de physique ou matière il ya
vraiment beaucoup de data est c'est fait
pour ça aussi qu'on n'en parle pas
pas énormément alors mais en fait ma
vision d'écologie ac c'est non mais
écologie j'ai un peu de mal parce que
c'est tellement connoté politiquement
que je suis capture si moi j'ai tendance
à dire environnement ce qui est pas très
bien non plus parce que ça voudrait dire
que c'est autour de nous et qu'on y est
séparé alors qu'au final nos sociétés
sont dans l'environnement tu as la plus
elle nous tombe dessus
on ramasse l'eau qui tombe on cultive
dans des champs qui sont déjà
l'environnement à quelqu'un c'est pas
parfait parce que ça a tendance à
externaliser et alimenter cette vision
d'une économie séparer de
l'environnement alors que l'économie est
inclus dans l'environnement et que nos
vies sont inclus dans l'économie quoi j
ph pas comment tu es enfin ou en gros
c'est les cercles concentriques pour moi
c'est pas trois boules séparés avec
juste des échanges mais je préfère quand
même un environnement qui est moins
connoté d'ailleurs même en anglais ici
d'environnementalistes pour eux pour
parler de ses mouvements
parce que l'écologie ça a été trop
marqué ma non politiquement et enfin
quand j'ai je sais pas quand je vais
dans ma famille connaissent un peu
maintenant ce que je fais mais quand je
vais dans des cercles un peu quand j'ai
dans ma belle famille est quelqu'un fait
ben voilà rodolphe il fait des vidéos
sur l'écologie ya toujours quelqu'un
pour me dira encore un qui va nous faire
chier fille nucléaire je suis non
justement
et ça c'est un truc
et pourtant les mouvements
environnementaux les premiers étaient
vraiment en phase avec les mouvements
universitaires
tu vas le way une des premières grandes
crises et 1963 un bouquin d'une biologie
qui s'appelait rachel carson et ça
s'appelait le printemps silencieux
ce livre là pourquoi le printemps
silencieux parce qu'elle a vu
chute incroyable de la population des
oiseaux printemps silencieux et à
l'époque c'était un pesticide compte
utiliser énormément
c'était le ddt qu'on utilise encore dans
certaines régions du monde pour lutter
contre le paludisme est en fait en plus
qu'on utilisait les quantités qui
paraîtrait l'astronomie qu'aujourd'hui
on avait passé notion de dose de
dangerosité et tout c'est en gros c'est
un pesticide qu'on a beaucoup utilisé en
sortie de seconde guerre mondiale qui a
participé à cette révolution verte qui a
permis de dégager d'énormes excédents
agricoles est en fait cette gêne un
processus de calcification donc les
oiseaux il répondait des autres os
fragiles voire sans coquille donc les
ouailles ont mûri direct et du coup il
ya eu il ya eu ce constat et il ya eu un
mouvement social est ensuite un
mouvement politique et on a interdit les
ddt ou réduit fortement les doses dans
les pays en crise après il ya eu les
problématiques des plus acide et les
problématiques des trous dans la couche
d'ozone
donc là encore le trou dans la couche
d'ozone c'est pas monsieur tout le monde
en sortant de chez lui qui se rendent
compte qu'il ya moins de zones dans la
stratosphère c'est vraiment quelque
chose
c'est un mouvement universitaire s'est
dit rechercher ces poussées pour
l'époque parce que c'est pas quelque
chose d'évident à à comprendre et à voir
c'est pas évident elle donc comprendre
la cause c'était certes un gaz de
synthèse qu'on faisait les cfc et du
coup ça a mené à une pression sociale
une pression politique qui a amené à
l'interdiction
en fait on a interdit régulièrement les
en fait on a mis des substituts en place
qui est impactée mois le trou dans la
couche d'ozone et au fur et à mesure ses
substituts sont interdits au fur et à
mesure qu'on trouve une solution
technique c'était pas un énorme problème
à résoudre parce que ça touche une
petite portion de l'économie
c'était tout ce qu'ils avaient dans les
rôles s'étaient tous qu'on utilisait
comme gaz réfrigérants d'utiliser encore
des cfc comme hcfc des on a mis un peu
de gêne à la place des clubs pour
diminuer l'impact mais mais mais on a
trouvé une solution et ça c'est fait
voilà du mouvement universitaire qui
explique les problèmes le politique la
société sonnant tard met en place des
régulations économiques des fois même
les entreprises je sais pas on peut
trouver en trouver ce qui en intérêt
donc elle pousse à aller dans le bon
sens on peut orienter un peu les marchés
et puis et puis il ya eu cette espèce de
divorce ou
les scientifiques ont commencé a
expliqué brian de changement climatique
de biodiversité et les mouvements écolos
ont fait un focus
je pense même en france en europe en
allemagne plus qu'ailleurs sur nucléaire
ogm
et puis ce divorce continue et ça c'est
un truc que j'ai beaucoup évolué alors
moi pour mon évolution sur l'écologie
alors déjà au début je te dirai quand
j'ai commencé à regarder ça j'étais même
pas certain que c'était l'âme je n'étais
pas certain que c'était très grave ça me
paraissent extrêmement loin on parle
souvent de la température en 2100 la
perte du billard site et je me disais ok
j'aime bien les petits animaux mais
qu'est ce que ça change finalement pour
les sociétés humaines nous en sept ont
fait disparaître un paquet d'animaux en
fait une appelle la mégafaune tous les
animaux de plus de 50 kg il y en a en
afrique et en asie parce que c'est là
que nos ancêtres ont évolué avec les
animaux quand ils ont quand ils ont
commencé à socialiser à avoir des
techniques de chasse pousser quoi et en
fait les autres endroits du monde où ils
sont arrivés après avoir appris à
chasser ils ont massacré les gros
animaux mais vraiment un massacre et
quand ils sont arrivés je sais pas en
amérique du nord ou en australie en
australie peut-être tu avais des passes
tu vois ce que celle où on bat non non
ouais c'est un espèce de chasse et un
koala cas de punch pas comment dire c
est l avait d énormes qui est celle
d'automne qui faisait des migrations
saisonnières ce qui est extrêmement rare
pour des managers est en fait à ces
bestioles là ils ont vu des doigts des
petits bus arrivait sur dota 2 qui
faisait 60 kg ils sont pas trop
inquiétés ils sont fait découper quoi et
en fait nos ancêtres quand ils sont
arrivés dans des nouvelles régions du
monde
eh ben on voit la mégafaune qui
disparaît en amérique du nord il y avait
des dromadaires il y avait des paresseux
géant des trucs qui faisait 2 mètres 52
au départ et ce quoi qu ils bouffaient
les avocats comme ça et qu'ils allaient
moins de problèmes que nous alors sortir
les noyaux et il y avait des dromadaires
et tout ça tout ça ça a été massacrée et
en fait c'est les européens qui ont
réintroduit les chevaux en amérique du
nord il n'est plus les indiens n'avait
pas de chevaux et donc alors ce que je
voulais dire là dessus c'est voilà cette
perte de diversité est ce qu'elle est
avec toi tu savais même pas au final
qu'est
et du coup ça c'était mon préjugé
c'était peu ce qu'est ce que c'est grave
tout ça est donc au fur et à mesure que
je regarde les différents problèmes
environnementaux
eh ben j'ai évolué sur ces questions là
et ce qui a beaucoup évolué mais aussi
c'est la vision que j'ai des politiques
sur l'environnement fin des mouvements
écologistes associatifs culturels entre
guillemets ce qui se raconte sur
l'écologie dans la société et les
politiques sur l'écologie et les
mouvements politiques sur l'écologie ça
c'est ça mon jugement là dessus a plutôt
évolué plutôt en mal et voilà après on
pouvait parler je sais pas s'il ya des
questions en particulier qui t'intéresse
mai et puis c'est des choses sur
lesquelles je continue aussi énormément
d'évoluer parce que c'est quand même
extrêmement difficile de comprendre les
impacts a par exemple été la notion de
l'effondrement qui je pense est assez
difficile à appréhender
est ce assez c'est une notion sur
laquelle j'ai du mal à avoir une opinion
définitive que je sais pas comment dire
manger je me rends bayésiens il est
sensible quoi ils bougent un peu dans le
temps est ce que je lis avec ce que
j'apprends ça je pense c'est un peu le
problème d'avoir une approche
scientifique de tout ça c'est que des
scientifiques en général c'est que du
coup en fait tu tapes adobe n'a rien
d'acquis et est à que des opinions qui
sont succès susceptible de bouger avec
les faits et des fois c'est des fois
c'est pas très agréable et du coup tu as
évolué comme encore l'effondrement
l'effondrement c'est l'effondrement
c'est une question extrêmement complexe
parce que les gens qui en parlant des
définitions différentes
google en fait d'un point de vue d'un
point de vue bayésiens c'était c'est
quelque chose que tu peux pas considéré
comme impossible
ça dépend qu'est ce qu'il vient en tête
quand on parle d'effondrement caisse
créée par jean j'entends beaucoup de
choses à la fois ça pourrait pas très
clair je pense que je rate un coup ça au
pic pétrolier mais peut-être que trompe
ouais mais je pense que c'est là je
pense que c'est la conceptualisation de
la plus immédiate la plus facile je
pense que le livre le plus important à
dire là-dessus le plus intéressant alors
il ya le grand classique ses limites à
la croissance alors il ya des rééditions
décès de l'île de 72 jeu pas citer
familier que ça le club de rome le
rapport milloz j'ai entendu par exemple
ça c'est intéressant parce que c'est la
dynamique des systèmes en fait c'est pas
du tout il faut un modèle relativement
sainte du monde et il regarde comment
ils évoluent en fonction de la
consommation de la population etc
et ça donne déjà des idées mais c'est
vraiment c'est un modèle qui se veut un
peu prospectifs tu as ce qui est très
différent du livre de pablo serving
comment tout peut s'effondrer qui est
plus une image de où on en est
aujourd'hui avec les grands cycles et un
livre historique très intéressant c'est
l'effondrement des sociétés complexes de
tender et lui et regarde ce qui s'est
enfin où lé société qui se sont
effondrés dans le passé est en fait les
dix mêmes ces approches ont une
définition assez différentes de
l'effondrement
pour certains c'est le moment la
structure en place ne peut plus subvenir
aux besoins de base de la population
pour d'autres c'est par ailleurs on
pourrait dire une réduction de la
population et où du niveau de vie pour
theater la halle approche historique
c'est assez intéressant il considère que
c'est une réduction de la complexité
en particulier il ya un exemple qui
revient souvent c'est la civilisation
maya est en fait il ya des études assez
récente qui qui montre je pense que
c'est assez consensuel et aujourd'hui je
pas certains chez c'est pas mon domaine
de recherche n'est que les utilisations
s'est effondré donc en fait les villes
ce sont des peuples etc mais qu' il n'y
a pas eu de réduction drastique
nécessairement de la population en fait
ils sont passés de société complexe à
organiser qui construisaient des temples
à cause de problèmes notamment le
rendement agricole des croissants ils
sont retournés à une agriculture
vivrière à un statut un peu plus de
chasseurs cueilleurs parce qu'ils n'ont
pas réussi à maintenir cette complexité
donc il ya eu un effondrement de cette
société mais sans nécessairement que ça
implique une chute forte de la
population et du coup comment penser
globalement ça alors la pensée la plus
globale je veux dire si c'est sûr que ça
convaincant c'est en fait nous on est là
à parler devant un ordi et à faire ce
qu'on fait sur youtube parce que en fait
nos sociétés arrivent à dégager
d'énormes excédents
on n'a pas besoin de faire l'agriculture
parce que les incultes heure arrive à
dégager plus de nourriture que ceux de
ton juste le ont besoin pour se nourrir
est pareil on agit dans un appartement
je n'ai jamais construit j'ai de l'eau
courante je me suis jamais occupé du
réseau d'eau d'électricité je me suis
jamais occupé l'électricité et donc en
fait on
il ya un énorme excédent qui nous permet
d'avoir la société tels qu'on apprécie
aujourd'hui où on est libre on a une
assurance maladie si on est malade ya
des gens qui prennent soin de nous où on
a une retraite quand on est vieux on
continue de consommer même si on produit
plus et ça s'est permis par des
excédents est en fait ces problèmes
environnementaux
ils vont toucher à mon avis ces
excédents de deux façons c'est un les
problèmes de pollution ce qu'ils font
souvent c'est que il oblige à utiliser
des excédents pour réparer des dégâts
donc on utilise l excellent pour soigner
les gens qui sont rendus malades par la
pollution de l'air par exemple on va
utiliser des excédents pour construire
des digues au fur et à mesure que
libations des mers augmente pour
je sais pas compensé les pertes quand il
ya des sécheresse exceptionnelle et
c'est donc il ya une partie des
excédents plutôt qu'utiliser pour faire
de la recherche pour faire de l'art pour
faire l'éducation on doit l'utiliser à
réparer des dégâts qui sont causés par
des problèmes environnementaux et
l'autre bout de la chaîne qui est plus
facile à comprendre encore c'est que ces
excédents on arrive à en avoir autant
aujourd'hui parce qu'on utilise des
ressources qui sont pour beaucoup non
renouvelables et en particulier les
ressources fossiles qui forment 85 % de
l'énergie utilisée dans le monde
et du coup au fur et à mesure que ça ça
va se raréfier on va devoir avoir des
processus qui dégageront - d'excellents
et on devra faire avec et du coup dans
l'effondrement des sociétés complexes
qu'il explique titer c'est un peu que la
complexité a un coût et que au fur et à
mesure que tu perds tes d'excédent où tu
es obligé de te lancer dans des dans des
processus de rendement décroissant donc
tu es puis sté sol ou alors tu peux
répondre on avait culture toujours plus
loin sur des sols de moins en moins
fertile où tu vas chercher des minerais
de moins en moins concentré donc il faut
de plus en plus d'efforts pour la même
chose eh bien tu perds ses excédents
donc les élites qui ne produisait rien
ou je sais pas la recherche
ben tu peux plus que la paire m parce
que quand faut couper quelque chose à
bien on va couper je sais pas les
traders ou la recherche
avant les incultes heure où les maçons
parce qu'on aura toujours besoin de se
nourrir de boire etc de se loger
donc c'est un peu c'est un peu ça l'idée
de la dea complexification c'est que
aujourd'hui l'erreur ce serait de
considérer que notre état actuel
l'énorme excédent qu'on dégage qui nous
permet de faire tout ce qu'on fait c'est
un état à perrin en fait on est arrivés
jusque là en particulier grâce aux
ressources fossiles qui sont un énorme
stock d'énergie et qui sont en quelque
sorte je sais pas un héritage à
accumuler sur des centaines de millions
d'années parce que c'est ça les ordres
de grandeur et qu'on est en train de
dilapider en deux siècles et et voilà si
quelqu'un reçoit un énorme héritage
qu'il est en train de vie fabuleux et
que ce sont revenus en fait c'est même
pas 10% de son train de vie une fois que
l'héritage et
dilapidé et retourne sur sont venus tous
qui retombe à 10% de son train de vie
c'est un peu ce qui risque d'arriver
avec les ressources dont je sais pas si
si conceptuellement tu vois un peu ce
que je veux dire moi c'est vraiment
comme ça je le vois en fait ces cds
pression qui s'accumule sur sur la
société après la particularité de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui par rapport aux
problèmes environnementaux qu'on a
résolues entre guillemets c'est que donc
on avait des problèmes avec les ddt on
les a interdits quand on a des problèmes
et que les sélections les interdits et
c'est des problèmes qui sont arrivés un
à un et qui était relativement séparés
des autres
et aujourd'hui quand on fait des
modifications dans le système
c'est difficile de pas couché un autre
problème tu en es un peu entouré
différents problèmes tels changements
climatiques
tu as les problèmes de profitations tas
je sais pas les problèmes de surpêche et
on a plein de problèmes et c'est
difficile de toucher un truc sans
toucher aux autres
il ya vraiment su su nway une pression
que précieux mais même il ya un truc qui
est marrant je vais finir l'étude j'ai
vu plusieurs personnes récemment parlé
quant à leur demander comment faire
bouger un peu les choses une
climatologues choix qui parler de ça
elle disait si vous voulez faire bouger
un peu les l'économie allait voir les
assureurs parce que les assureurs
eh bien ils ont un vrai pouvoir
économique et ils ont une vraie
conscience des problèmes
environnementaux parce que eux ils les
pays ces dégâts donc ils voient déjà qui
s'accumulent et je pense que penser
l'assurance c'est assez intéressant pour
penser un peu comment ces problèmes
peuvent s'exercer sur nos sociétés à
nous relativement épargnée jusque là
donc l'assurance c'est quoi ces eaux
mais dans une boîte commune
tous un peu d'argent je pense qu'on paye
tous des assurances est la contrepartie
c'est que si un jour on a un coup du
sort si un jour on a un pépin si on se
fait voler notre voiture c'est notre
maison brûle si on a une innovation et
bien on est compensée et dans nos
contrées le changement climatique ça
veut dire un peu plus de phénomènes
extrêmes donc des sécheresses qui
peuvent détruire un peu les cultures des
incendies on n'a pas eu trop récemment
en france il ya eu ailleurs en europe
qui ont été assez violent donc les
incendies ça peut être des pertes
d'applications ça peut être des pertes
économiques et des inondations ça on en
a eu en france qui ont même qu'il ya des
gens est en fait au fur et à mesure que
ça s'accumule
le coût de ces coups du sort augmente
donc il faut tous se mettre un peu plus
dans la boîte et donc ça c'est pas déjà
c'est une façon de retranscrire ses
impacts environnementaux en termes de
pouvoir d'achat de qualité de vie mais
surtout la question qui se posera un
jour c'est quand la boîte est trop
grosses pour qu'on puisse en supporter
les coûts que certaines personnes
puissent en supporter les coûts comment
on fait est ce qu'on veut mais est-ce
qu'on remettra en cause parce que c'est
quand même c'est quand même assez
sécurisant c'est quand même bien
pratique c'est l'assurance mais il ya
les assurés aujourd'hui qui explique que
un monde à deux trois degrés n'est pas
assurable pour certains risquent donc
demain s'il ya trop d'innovations en
france si le coût est trop élevé pour la
société dans ses plus assurable et les
gens qui sont en zone inondable qui sont
dans les régions problématique est bas
le jour ils perdent leur maison ils
perdent leur maison et ça c'est quand
même des changements économiques
hyperimportant pas ça veut quand même
dire quelque chose je pense
réponse c'est intéressant pour tous de
ce point de vue des assureurs
du coup taille et parce que les
assurances ont énormément de données en
fait que ce qu'ils s'intéressent
beaucoup à cette question et j'imagine
et donc je payais des collaborations
entre les chercheurs en sciences de
l'environnement et les assureurs publics
et des trucs à un outil là bas alors oui
je sais pas exactement mais je suis prêt
à parier que oui et même quand tu
recherches un peu assureurs risques
climatiques il ya pas mal de
documentation et montrent qu'il ya déjà
des effets en cours mais même dans notre
pays et surtout alors non seulement ils
sont intéressés par ce que le racontent
les sélections du climat
je pense qu'ils vont voir des experts de
ces différents trucs pour savoir à quoi
s'attendre dans le futur ça paraît assez
évident mais c'est aussi assez
intéressant même pour pour les
scientifiques du climat ou même ou pour
les sciences environnement parce qu'en
fait c'est des experts du risque donc de
toi de juger un peu la probabilité date
venu d'événement est ce que ça pourrait
impliquer
c'est leur domaine d'expertisé d'avoir
ce de juger ce type d'objet donc il ya
une vraie interaction et ils sont
beaucoup plus haut fait tout ça que les
milieux économiques financiers
traditionnels parce que eux ils ont un
contact avec le réel que beaucoup de
milieux économiques et financiers ont
perdu les gens qui parient sur les
stocks de matières premières je pense
qu'ils s'en rendent pas compte que ce
qu'il ya derrière
alors que les assureurs quand ils
remboursent les dégâts d'une innovation
dans une zone ils ont beaucoup plus
conscience de ce qu'il ya derrière
ils sont obligés en fait de par leurs
métiers de rester attaché à ce que
veulent vraiment dire ces événements
pour pouvoir voir ce que ça veut dire
demain et pouvoir tout simplement
prévoir les coûts et prévoir l'heure et
leurs bénéfices quoi donc mais là en
quelques mois j'ai alors j'ai plus
retenu exactement et j'ai deux trois
personnes qui ont fait cette même
réflexion sur aller voir les assureurs
dans le milieu économique puisque les
autres parce que c'est ce qu'ils ont
conscience de ces changements et je
trouve ça assez intéressant que je
m'approche et vient même un dernier truc
et qui même globalement
la nage par les assurances un peu
particulière pour qu'on comprenne ce que
ça veut dire pour nous mais après il ya
tous les systèmes de l'état de
catastrophe naturelle de dédommagement
des agriculteurs quand il ya des grosses
sécheresses ou des gros orages et c est
là c'est un poids sur la société donc
c'est quelque chose qui finit par se
retranscrire ce soit en coupe ailleurs
soit on taxe plus quoi donc si c'est une
pression moi je vois ça faut le voir
comme des pressions économiques en fait
qui s'ajouté qui nous éloigne de qu'on
pourrait considérer comme un optimum pas
loin même si ça dépend beaucoup des
régions du monde quand même
ouais ça fait penser à une amie qui
faisait son post doc financé par axa
assurances sur en astrophysique sur à
l'étude des tempêtes solaires et cc
c'est un peu un des biais d'autres
raisons pour lesquelles je vous dit en
fait ça parce que ça c'est un vrai
risque en fait c'est vrai c'est un vrai
c'est un vrai risque c'est votre cas
suffisant pour que les assurances se
prennent ça au sérieux et le dernier
gros événement de ce type là on n'avait
pas encore d'électronique et ça avait
fait péter les lignes de télégrammes des
gravats laissés licra ou telegraph
merci j'ai oublié télégramme c'est
l'équitation plus tôt et du coup ces
trucs là donc c'était juste des lignes
de cuivre quoi avec ça avait fait sauter
les laiteries qui utilisés ou debout
c'était c'est assez incroyable pour
l'époque et il n'avait pas trop compris
ce qui s'était passé il y avait des
lignes comme ça qui est vérifiée donc si
tu arrive aujourd'hui avec les
chroniques en allant société les
dommages matériels serait énorme énorme
mais mais c'est sous ce qui est bien
c'est que du coup c'est niveau des
assurances que que ce genre de risque
est ce que c'est si oui à des biais par
lequel j'ai appris que ceux des tempêtes
solaires était un vrai risque donc tu
vois je pense que ça serait intéressant
d'étudier un peu plus à son utilisation
sont très intéressé par ça moi j'ai été
j'ai eu l'occasion assez d'être invité à
une conférence d'assureurs il y avait
tous des pleins de de directeur de
de la recherche et développement dans
des compagnies d'assurances s'appelle
l'assurance de l'argus et parce qu'ils
sont extrêmement a été assez justement
par les technologies d'intelligence
artificielle pour pour essayer de
prédire les risques à venir
ouais oui aussi d'autres applications
comme par exemple la détection de
fraudes qui les intéresse beaucoup
mais est-ce que ça c'est un milieu ça
c'est intéressant de creuser un peu plus
leurs données et du coup sur
l'effondrement sans toi ça te paraît
plausible d'hugo sur une barge pareils
combien pour un effondrement
pour quelle date aussi en fait comme en
arrière je pense que c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut pas considérer comme un
possible
ça serait une erreur et je pense que
c'est même quelque chose qu'on peut
considérer comme assez probable mais ça
dépend beaucoup de ce que tu te
considères comme un effondrement et est
par contre j'ai beaucoup de mal avec les
discours qui y voient une fatalité
je pense que c'est dangereux et je pense
que pareille d'un point de vue estime
logique tu peux tu peux pas associé non
plus une propriété de 100% ça tu as
tellement de sens surtout sur des choses
aussi incertaine
et j'ai l'impression que historiquement
quand on regarde le rapport du club de
rome ou genre de choses là les gens qui
utilisent des systèmes complexes donc il
faut essaye de faire des modèles de
l'économie ou de la société ont une
prudence épistémique est ce qu'on
appelle la colle absolue au gie
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression qu'elle
laisse un peu de côté cette prudence est
pisté milk et puis après en fait le truc
c'est que on s'imagine un effondrement
mondial mais toutes les régions ne sont
pas aussi vénérables et pas au même
phénomène et c'est assez improbable que
ce soit ça c'est improbable que ce soit
un phénomène synchrone partout dans le
monde en fait il n'y a pas tellement de
raison et après pour pour pour une date
qui est extrêmement difficile pour moi
c'est que on peut regarder les tendances
physique on peut regarder les impacts
qu'auront changement climatique ce que
ça peut coûter on peut regarder ce que
ça veut dire pour l'agriculture on peut
regarder où on est le pic pétrolier ou
rate
en fait ce qu'on a c'est une tendance de
fond donc on rate ce qui pourrait
déclencher par un phénomène extrême il
suffit je sais pas d'une sécheresse
généralisée pour pour mettre un peu à ma
l'agriculture et on aurait déjà des
problèmes sociaux il ya des gens qui
considèrent que c'est ce qui s'est passé
dans les printemps arabes en fait la
russie en 2010 il ya une grosse
sécheresse ils avaient perdu entre un
tiers et un quart de la récolte et c'est
des exportateurs énorme de blé est en
fait ces pays qui ont connu les
printemps arabes c'est des pays où la
population dépense une bonne partie de
son revenu pour le pain et quand il ya
eu cette perte agricole la russie a dit
on exporte rares y installer après les
phénomènes d'amplification financier
parce que les gens se mettent à paris à
la hausse est évidemment donc tout ça
c'est un peu pourri par l'économie mais
résultat c'est que le blé a été très
très cher le pain a grimpé cdpi en plus
qui à cause des attentats avaient moins
de revenus touristiques et à cause du
fait que le pétrole était moins cher que
ces années là les pays producteurs
avaient moins de revenus donc tu vois
que la balance a été sérieusement
affecté la et du et du coup ben il ya
des gens qui sort dans la rue parce que
le pain est devenu trop cher donc
donc ça c'est un truc qu'on rate avec
les tendances et la survenue
d'événements je sais pas comment dire
extrême aléatoire parce qu'on voit que
des tendances ne pourra jamais dire il y
aura une sécheresse ans en 2021
originaux peux tu dire que la volatilité
de certains bah ouais c'est une notion
de volatilité de sensibilité genre ah
ouais ouais ouais enfin il ya une
approche probabiliste et
on peut le faire sur des événements
généraux genre y aura plus en plus
sécheresse et puis sur des événements
extrêmes y aura de plus en plus de
sécheresse qui dure tant pis les
touristes et récoltent donc ça c'est une
limite un peu la proche parent tendance
le grosses limites c'est que ya aucune
raison que l'accumulation de pression
sur le système économique n'engendre pas
de crise économique ou social est le
genre on peut s'imaginer voilà il ya ce
pétrole là on continue jusqu'au bout moi
je suis prêt à parier que l'arrivée
l'arabie saoudite n'a aucune raison de
vendre son pétrole jusqu'au bout
arrivé à un certain moment ils peuvent
avoir intérêt pour eux de garder leurs
réserves sur donc en fait il peut y
avoir des phénomènes je sais pas comment
dire de deux claques et où des
phénomènes peuvent enfin tu vas pas du
tout linéaire pas du tout on continue
dans l'économie et ça ça peut arriver
assez rapidement et il suffit de bloquer
trois raffineries en france pour voir
l'impact que cela peut avoir sur
l'économie de pays typiquement ce que
nous on sort pas beaucoup de pétrole du
sol 1 donc on serait vite vous serez
vite dans la mouise et salé les crises
économiques et politiques peuvent
advenir bien avant les problèmes
environnementaux qui sont la tendance de
fond et je pense d'ailleurs que 1 des
dangers pour la compréhension des enjeux
environnementaux
c'est que on n'identifie pas les raisons
tu vois que s'il est des tensions sur le
pétrole
on se dise que ce soit juste l'économie
et au politique parce que c'est ce qui
bougera avant tu à cesser le bruit
autour du signal et qu'on voit pas le
signal en dessous et du coup on met pas
en place les bonnes actions parce qu'on
n'identifie pas le signal et ça c'est
quelque chose qui me fait c'est pas que
ça me fait un peu peur mais je pense que
ça peut être une des façons de vraiment
planté sur ces questions c'est que on
voit des déplacements de population et
on dise que ce soit juste pour des
raisons politiques ethniques religieuses
et qu'on ne voit pas les tendances de
fond et du coucou m'adresse pas les
tendances de fond est que ces évènements
se multiplier s'aggrave je sais pas si
c'est clair typiquement
les tensions géopolitiques serait
espèces de chênes qui tombe à cause de
la tempête et méo et cécile chaîne qui
casse tout l'est du coup mais c'est
plutôt non seulement possible
ouais c'est plutôt dépression qui
s'accumulent et en fait ça fait céder
les endroits qui sont déjà fragiles donc
là où on verra des problèmes ces deux
endroits où il ya déjà des tensions
économiques des tensions politiques des
tensions sociales et d'ailleurs j'avais
été ça assez marqué quand j'avais
commencé à regarder le changement
climatique j'avais lu un livre blanc je
crois ou l'équipement de l'armée
américaine qui était très au fait du
changement climatique alors que vous
traînez pas là pas l'air d'y croire et
il appelait ça un multiplicateur de
menaces tueur en fait il y à des menaces
dans le monde pour des raisons externes
et au fur et à mesure que tapie des
dépressions en fait chez pat à des
problèmes d'eau qui font des populations
se déplacent ça évidemment les
répercussions économiques et politiques
qui vont interne déclenché des
migrations des conflits et du coup voilà
c'était c'était cette illustration de
multiplicateur de ménage trouvé ça assez
approprié
je pense qu'on dira jamais ce
déplacement de population cette guerre
est une guerre climatique parce que ça
se sera jamais le seul facteur en fait
c'est toujours multifactorielles mais
c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut
qu'il faut taire ces facteurs
environnementaux faut l'identifier parce
que ils font partie du problème est que
si on les identifie pas on ne va pas les
adresser et on rate une partie des
causes sa séparation tout ça je suis pas
quelqu'un de très rassurée sur les
évolutions en cours et et je pense
d'ailleurs que c'est globalement
partagées dans mon milieu forme
comment dire il ya des gens qui sont
très affectés par des discours de
militants ou par des dauphins qui sont
massacrés aux iles féroé moi vraiment ce
qui me fait un coup au moral c'est quand
je lis des articles scientifiques qui
sont extrêmement pessimiste où tu vois
tu utilisais article n'est pas sur la
perte de biodiversité ou des
scientifiques qui ont normalement une
approche assez neutre à ses objectifs
commencer à expliquer que c'est des
problèmes majeurs que enfin commence à
aimer des opinions sur les changements
en cours qui sont extrêmement graves en
général c'est quelque chose quoi quand
tu lis des articles sur le blues des
climatologues parce que c'est des gens
qui explique que ça va de plus en plus
mal et qu'en fait tout le monde s'en
fout et et qu'ils n'arrivent pas à à
vivre leur objet d'étude aaa à évaluer
ses impacts et se rendent compte qu'on
réagit pas et que eux comprennent en
fait ce qui va nous attendre à ce que la
plupart des gens au final c'est pas trop
dur pour moralement parce qu'ils
comprennent pas les enjeux n'ont cessé
vraiment quand je lis les opinions des
scientifiques là c'est là c'est plus dur
c'est plus dur moralement mais je pense
à devait des millions c'est extrêmement
dur de travailler
t'imagines à ta passion dans la vie
c'est les petits animaux qui va étudier
la biodiversité et arrive à une époque
où en fait tu deviens un conteur des
espèces qui disparaissent quoi tu es là
pour pour rédiger les
j'ai vu comment envier à la fin des
journaux là quand il ya eu un mort et
non franchement a détruit qui va les
plus affectées c'est quand je faisais
mes trucs sur la perte de biodiversité
et j'étais tombé sur une vidéo je crois
du national geographic où il montrait le
le dernier individus d'une espèce de
grenouille arboricole en plus assez
mignonne des grenouilles assez jolie et
en fait c'était un mal je crois et il
appelait il cherchait des femelles donc
il passait son temps à crier mais il y
avait plus aucun d'autres individus de
son espèce qui existait que d'imaginer
ce que ça veut dire quand même
psychologiquement moralement il y avait
un mec qui témoigner parce qu'il prenait
des photos et des belles photos de ces
dernières individus il fait il disait
lui ce qui s'est fixé comme mission dans
la vie c'est de photographier c'est and
links s'appelle end les derniers
représentants d'une espèce
enfin ils voulaient du coup qu'on est un
peu conscience de ces espèces qui
disparaissent grâce à ça et ça mais je
trouve ça moralement je trouve ça
absolument horrible et un très bon
article wikipédia d'ailleurs je pense
une meilleure en anglais sur les links
code les derniers représentants des
décisions et souvent cdn mots en fête
qui passe de leur vie à essayer
d'appeler des congénères sont jamais
avoir de réponse et c'est franchement
c'est horrible c'est ça c'est un truc
conceptuellement je trouve ça assez
difficile ou habbo j'ai juste essayé de
clore ces partis un peu sur les pros
risques pour environnementaux disons que
qui quelle probabilité tu mettras et
pour que dix ans en 2040 on va dire il
se soit passé parce que je présume est
l'un des pires scénarios à ça serait
alors une de guerre mondiale comme ça je
sache je ne sais pas il est tous assez
difficile de penser les réactions
politiques ou économiques
ce qu'on risque de voir c'est une
accumulation des pressions économiques
donc globalement une perte du niveau de
vie voire une perte de population dans
certaines régions du monde qui sont
exposés après en 2040 c'est c'est assez
proche quand je pense que 2040 ou est ce
que je pourrais m'avancer
2040 il ya des chances que l' on est on
est déjà passé le pic pétrolier donc en
fait on serait dans une dans une
récession énergétique une diminution de
au moins sur le pétrole est en fait le
pétrole c'est assez particulier parce
que c'est c'est dur a substitué quoi on
peut pas substituer le pétrole avec du
gaz on n'a pas les mêmes usages par ya
les gens qui chauffent au fioul mais
majoritairement le pétrole on utilise
pour se déplacer et du coup bah ça aura
des implications économiques et en fait
on derrag une récession économique
on peut en voir avant pour d'autres
raisons il ya pas besoin d'une raison
environnementale pour qui l'économie
partent un peu en vrille on l'a déjà vu
mais mais non je pense qu avant 2040
on aura un pic pétrolier qui est déjà
passée pour le conventionnel en fait le
pétrole le plus propre
enfin le plus idéal qu'on y est pour
l'instant en compost des pétroles lourds
des pétroles de schiste et les sables
bitumineux qui en plus des pétroles qui
ont beaucoup plus impacts
environnementaux et qui ont un moins bon
au taux de retour énergétique donc en
fait sa demande plus d'efforts dans il
ya quelque chose et il ya des gens
soient compass le pic pétrolier avant
après c'est pas ce n'est pas
l'apocalypse en fait c'était sur la le
moi j'envisage pas du tout la fin de
l'espèce par exemple ou pas pour des
raisons environnementales
mais c'est plus c'est que c'est plus une
dégradation des relations économiques
quoi est le problème
en fait ce qui l'a le plus problématique
je pense c'est les troubles sociaux qui
peuvent en découler
à cette échéance relativement courte
parce que mais ça je pense que leur
écart n'a déjà pas mal parlé donc ceux
qui n'ont pas écouté peuvent aller
écouter hurricanes mais c'est que l'on
vit dans des sociétés qui sont calmes
très inégalitaire même d'un point de vue
historique et cette inégalité jusque là
étaient supportés par un espèce de pacte
social qui voulait que ok peut-être que
les tranches les plus riches de la
population s'enrichissent plus vite que
les autres
mais tout le monde s'enrichissait et si
tu rentres dans une récession économique
si tu diminues les flux de matériaux en
fait les flux
de pétrole de métaux etc qui rentrent
dans la société et bassett croissance de
l'économie matérielle qui est sale un
peu qu'ils comptent elles risquent de
diminuer voire de s'inverser et là les
inégalités vont devenir intolérable et
d'ailleurs même les gens qui ont une
approche historique j'ai parlé de
l'effondrement des sociétés complexes de
tainter on pourrait parler de jared
diamant d'aussi effondrement et quand tu
regardes ça il explique que les
inégalités sont un facteur aggravant et
qu'il ya même des sociétés où la cause
principale d'effondrement celebrate
c'est en fait à différentes classes qui
se constitue et qui finit par se faire
la guerre et c'est ce qui pose
l'effondrement est en tout cas quand il
commence à avoir des pressions avoir des
sociétés très égalitaire c'est un
facteur aggravant
mais je pense que ça se comprend bien
c'est que si tout le monde s'enrichit un
peu on accepte que monsieur une rolex et
une grosse voiture que des gens puissent
se déplacer tous les jours en avion et
pas d'autres si on commence à ne plus
pouvoir mettre du beurre dans les
haricots ça paraît beaucoup beaucoup
plus injuste en fait pas du tout ça
permet de transitionner petit à petit
vers qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
la conférence que j'ai fait il ya pas
longtemps la sur les impacts du
changement climatique j'ai essayé de
réfléchir un peu à sa place
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et vient
alors évidemment on peut faire nos
petits gestes individuels
donc là faites votre bilan carbone par
exemple si vous êtes embêté par le
changement climatique et et si vous êtes
plus embêté par la perte de biodiversité
faites attention à votre alimentation
typiquement ça on pourrait on pourrait
parler des gestes manuels sais pas si
c'est utile
[Musique]
je pense que beaucoup de gens qui sont
procurés par tous à essaye d'en faire
après la grosse limite de ces gestes là
c'est que ce sont les gens qui les font
qui emporte la charge
moi quand j'étais quand j'étais gamin je
voulais de chercheurs en amazonie après
j'ai vu que j'étais allergique au pollen
je pense que je suis embêté et j'ai
toujours été émerveillé par les oiseaux
etc
et j'irai jamais en amazonie je pense
parce que je suis un peu embêté pour
prendre l'avion peut-être que je veux
reprendre un jour mais pour l'instant je
le prends pas
et en fait je suis le seul à souffrir du
fait de ne pas avoir ces oiseaux alors
que le fait que je ne met pas de frein
plus tôt si j'avais émis du co2 et bien
tout le monde en souffrirait un tout
petit peu parce que c'est pas mes
émissions qui vont changer le monde mais
si tu vois ce que je veux dire je vais
la perte de liés à ces gestes
individuels mais tout le monde
bénéficier des conséquences et ça c'est
un jeu auquel serré c'est difficile que
tout le monde rentre dans le rang donc
l'idée d'après ces serait de généraliser
ces gestes individuels donc finalement
les imposer aux autres c'est un peu la
logique de nos sociétés démocratiques
c'est pas parce que je roule en
respectant les limites de vitesse que
tout le monde va le faire il faut un
cadre qui punissent qui roule pas etc
il faut un cadre commun et et c'est
comme ça que ça marche et c'est pour ça
que qu'on n'a pas trop de morts sur les
routes c'est parce qu'on a mis un cadre
en place donc là l'idée ce serait de
mettre un cadre en place pour limiter
ces impacts du changement climatique
parce qu'on considère que d'un point de
vue global ce sont des impacts négatifs
pour l'économie et les sociétés humaines
et du coup l'étape d'après ça serait un
peu voilà de mettre en place d une
régulation un des mesures politiques
pour pour lutter efficacement contre
tous à qu'idiot baliserait en quelque
sorte ces gestes un duel c'est un peu
l'idée de la taxe carbone par exemple
c'est d'avoir un signal prix sur les os
os fossiles pour en diminuer la
consommation même si elle a été assez
mal mise en place et j'en ai parlé dans
leur tour sur mon passage à la télé un
peu ce qui fonctionne pas trop là dessus
ça serait l'idée du quotas carbone
d'égaliser dont j'avais parlé donc là en
fait on aurait tous le droit d'émettre
un peu de co2 et on choisirait ce qu'on
veut donc ce n'est pas une dictature
absolue on interdirait pas forcément un
comportement mais il faudrait essayer
diminuer les comportements qui nous
nuisent tous en fête et c'est déjà
quelque chose qu'on fait pour des
problématiques de pollution de l'air
pour la consommation du tabac pour la
conduite sommation de l'alcool ce n'est
pas du tout quelque chose de novateur
même si l'échelle que demanderait la
lutte contre le changement climatique
serait assez assez forte
donc ça serait une idée ça serait passé
à l'échelon politique
et je pense moi mais c'est aussi pour ça
que je fais une chaîne youtube donc là
tu as un gros billet en interviewant des
gens qui font des chaînes youtube je
pense qu'un truc hyper important c'est
d'expliquer tout ça d'en parler d'en
parler autour de soi parce que c'est
souvent là qu'on a le plus d'impact et
d'identifier ce qui se passe ce que ça
veut dire de commencer à mettre en place
la culture qui va avec
j'ai fait un matériau ya pas longtemps
mais qui a volé quand je lui ai dit que
pour moi ces questions c'était une
guerre culturelle
tu vois c'est un affrontement de
discours en fait et pour l'instant les
discours sont incompatibles avec les
limites physiques de la planète est en
fait sont tellement éloignés de ce qu'on
comprend du monde aujourd'hui que il
empêche de le concevoir
je sais pas comment tu penses quoi tu
penses à quoi comme discours plus
concret bas par exemple tous les modèles
économiques pratiquement considère la
croissance comme comme base de tout
raisonnement les politiques aussi il ya
tous les discours même sur une évolution
constante et positive de la société
humaine où les discours de
d'amélioration constante de la
technologie qui seraient des discours
qui serait justifiée si on avait
construit petit à petit nos sociétés sur
des flux renouvelables tu vois là ça
serait logique si on avait gratté un peu
de vent qu'on avait on avait appris à
mieux gérer le vent et c'est qu'on avait
construit tout ce qu'on a sur des flux
physiques renouvelables on pourrait voir
cette amélioration mais en fait tout ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui on la construit sur
un capital 1 qu un arbre deux choses
différentes et je pense qu'il faut faire
parler un peu de la biodiversité parce
que j'étais un peu attendu dans d'autres
vidéos et j'aimerais revenir sur
certains points mais en gros nabati nos
sociétés sur d'un côté des stocks de
ressources épuisables donc quand ces
stocks disparaît c'est pas du tout
évident qu'on arrive à le substitut et
si tu t'amuses a tracé la consommation
d'énergie dans le temps
tu vois que ça augmente énormément avec
les ressources possibles en fait on
utilise toujours à peu près autant de
biomasse qu'avant ça n'a pas changé
l'utilisation de bois notamment dans les
pays développés et a eu tout le fossile
qui s'est ajoutée et les gens qui parie
qu'on aura le même mode de vie demain et
le même niveau de vie eh bien ils font
le pari que demain 85% de ce fossile on
va le substituer par des trucs
renouvelables parce qu'on n'a pas réussi
à faire jusque là mais ça c'est pas du
tout un pari
c'est très loin d'être une certitude ce
qui peut aussi arriver c'est qu'au fur
et à mesure que ça des croix et dans
cette énergie
on ne l'a plus et du coup ça veut dire
qu'on perd beaucoup de choses qu'on a
aujourd'hui et je pense je pense que là
il ya un truc hyper important en fait
c'est que on considère comme acquis un
paquet de choses qu'on a aujourd'hui
le fait que la lumière s'allume quand on
appuie sur un bouton qu'on ait de l'eau
courante qu'on ait une alimentation
saine parce qu'on ne se rend pas compte
de tout ce que ça représente en dessous
alors il ya une étape de la
compréhension qui est le manteau de
laine la date 26 donc de comprendre que
c'est une multitude d'acteurs que c'est
une multitude de connaissances dans
l'économie qui arrive à produire ce
qu'on a et l'étape qui manque à beaucoup
de gens et qui manquent même à la
conception d'économie c'est de voir les
flux physiques qui ceux qui sont en
dessous de ça donc en fait que qu'est-ce
qu'on peut prendre des vies dans ok
évident une bonne partie de
l'agriculture aux etats unis aujourd'hui
au lieu d'utiliser l'eau qui tombe du
ciel au lieu d'utiliser l'eau des
rivières qu'on pourrait considérer comme
renouvela même si le changement
climatique affecte beaucoup les
précipitations la répartition on peut
considérer ça comme renouvelable et bien
ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils tapent
énormément dans des nappes phréatiques
les nappes phréatiques se rechargent
mais elle se recharge à un rythme qui
est assez limité parce qu'il faut que
l'eau s'infiltre et tu sais si tu tapes
plus que la nappe se rechargent tu tapes
dans un stock d'eau quand tu arrives au
fond de ta poche d'eau et il n'y a plus
d'eau en fait donc tout que tu as
construit comme agriculture et toutes
les sociétés qui en dépendent elles
disparaissent
tu vois ce que je veux dire et et l'idée
que la société ne cesse de s'améliorer
qu'on est que quand fait tout ça c'est
acquis et qu'on regarde que ce qui va
s'ajouter et bien elle est fausse parce
que ce qu'on considère comme acquis
aujourd'hui repose sur des choses
cliquetis qui sont remises en question
sur des stocks qui disparaissent et je
pense que sur cette nappe phréatique
c'est assez évident et d'ailleurs les
endroits du monde en fait ces nappes
phréatiques on les vit tellement plus
vite qu on les remplit que le sol
s'affaisse et au dessus tu crées une
cavité de mexico c'est assez
impressionnant parce que il ya des
photos où tu vois les rues et en fait
les comment dire les maisons au lieu
d'être aligné ça fait des vagues la rue
les endroits qui sont plus à fait c'est
que d'autres ça c'est ouf
je conseille fortement il ya un truc de
vulgarisation qui est pas mal c'est
netflix à une série de documentaires qui
s'appelle explained ils ont traduit sa
part en bref en français ça dure une
quinzaine de minutes c'est assez
marrante un épisode sur la capote on a
un outil à l'épi ce vent d'autan à un
autre sur l'orgasme féminin donc c'est
vraiment aux chiens lapins et c'est
vraiment un format assez court et
interviews des experts et l'épisode sur
l'eau était pas trop mal c'est assez
c'est assez intéressant grille donc d'un
côté tu as idée de stock et là je pense
que c'est assez facile à concevoir et de
l'autre côté à l'idée de on a aussi
construit une partie tout ça sur un
capital naturel qu'on détruit donc ça
serait plutôt enfin ça rejoint un peu
les ressources mais sait pas vraiment si
tu crois une population de poissons par
exemple en fait il va y avoir elle va
plafonner à cause de son milieu ce qu'on
appelle la carling capacity la capacité
de portage
je sais pas la blague la capacité
maximum d'un milieu et un gros si tu
commences à trois poissons dans un lac
bas au début ça va croître lentement
parce qu'ils sont pas beaucoup faut
qu'ils se trouvent et oui galère au bout
d'un moment ils sont assez nombreux donc
ils vont commencer à croître de plus en
plus vite donc tu as une espèce de
d'exposants ciel qui se met en place
et puis ils atteignent un peu aux
limites de leurs systèmes donc si c'est
un lac ça peut être l'espace ça peut
être la production d'algues et c'est
donc là tu vas avoir une asymptote et au
final qui finit avec une silhouette
c'est clair qu un jour dans la cour et
en fait du coup si tu regardes la
production en fonction la population tu
passes par un maximum qui est un peu
près au milieu quand est très proche de
la population totale est pas beaucoup
qui peut s'agiter et en fait si tu
pêches moins que ce maximum et battu
peut pêcher pour toujours tu vois tu vas
trouver un état d'équilibré ou en fait
ce que tu pêches et un égal à ce qui est
produit par milieu alors il ya un peu de
variabilité donc vous faut éviter de
pêcher exactement au maximum sinon il ya
une année ou plus où tu vas ratée
conclue le coup et tu vas être pouilles
et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que les
régulations empêche on utilise des
quotas parce qu'on arrive assez bien
estimé ça et qu'on régule aurait
beaucoup moins bien ça avec des taxes
donc en fait on met un quota pour rester
dans des populations optimale il ya
plein de régions du monde où en fait ces
stocks sont les fruits et le pire c'est
qu'une fois que tu as passé ce max et
ben ya de moins en moins que les
produits chaque année
donc tu continues tu perds énormément
été tuées rod ton stock et ça ça peut
mettre des décennies à venir
et en plus c'est très grave chez nous qu
est ce qui se passerait en aurait moins
de sushis ça serait peut-être un sushi
pour les amateurs mais pas pourtant de
lencquesaing dans beaucoup de pays du
monde ces apports de poisson c'est des
apports primordiaux pour certains
éléments et notamment pour llyod qui est
hyper important pour le développement du
cerveau l'expression crétin des alpes en
fait c'est des gens qui avaient des
carences en iode parce qu'il était très
loin de la mer ils n'avaient pas de
produits de la mer et du coup ça fait
que c'était par des gens qui avaient des
déficiences mentales quoi donc donc donc
ces populations de poissons sont
importantes et ça c'est une illustration
de ce que j'appelle moi un capital
d'un point de vue économique c'est que
voilà ce stock c'est un capital tous les
ans il peut il peut donner un revenu
poisson qu'on peut utiliser
or ça plaira pas peut-être aux franges
de vega nous les franges les plus
extrêmes de de l'écologie mais moi je
considère qu'une pêche durable n'est pas
un gros mot tu vois et en fait à un
capitaine naturel que tu peux exploiter
et ça se rapproche un peu de tout ce qui
est sur la biodiversité c'est que c'est
ce que ce conte des fréquents détruit la
biodiversité ce qu'on détruit quand on
détruit les stocks de poissons c'est un
capital les stocks de poisson si on n'a
pas trop dérégulé on peut arrêter de
pêcher et se reconstituer et avoir une
gestion durable la biodiversité vraiment
c'est du capital qu'on détruit et non
seulement ça rend des services à nos
sociétés donc ça on peut le considérer
comme un revenu et un revenu qu'on
aurait beaucoup beaucoup mal à évaluer
connexion donc on peut penser à la
pollinisation qui est le cas classique
mais en fait dans les services
écosystémiques on regarde pas ce que
font que les animaux on regarde aussi ce
que font les écosystèmes en général donc
la filtration d'eau par l'infiltration
dans les nappes phréatiques ou ou le
fait que des bandes de forêts protège
des inondations parce que ça absorbe de
l'eau protège du vent les forêts
localement ça des gros effets sur les
précipitations ont fait ça peut prouver
qu'elle n'est plus enfin c'est assez
compliqué et donc toutes ces choses là
c'est des services écosystémiques
et au fur et à mesure qu'on détruit sa
ont détruit ses services ont détruit un
capital et il ya un autre aspect je
pense à que la diversité qui est assez
mal compris c'est que c'est un énorme
stock de tiens comment ils définiraient
la diversité des vivants
mais faute ouais peut-être fini de un
peu sur ça mais ouais enfin tout cas
intuitivement c'est en gros le la
variété de en termes de quantité mais
surtout en termes de tout est différent
ce génétique entrées différentes espèces
animales présentes sur terre que je
soupçonne ouais il ya vraiment cette
idée là et du coup faut faire attention
à ne pas y mettre la notion d'individu
tu vois si en soi s'ils ont des
problèmes avec la disparition d'un
individu bain à chaque fois qu'une yann
bouffin un z y aurait un problème en
fait c'est vraiment l'idée bio dit enfin
de diversité justement alors en fait il
ya trois paramètres donc c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas quantifiable parce
que ces trois choses complètement
différentes
tu as la diversité un peu des milieux
naturels des écosystèmes des
interactions si on lit entre les espèces
talent et diversité des espèces est à la
diversité un intra espèces donc la
diversité génétique au sein d'une espèce
qui est une variable hyper importante
pour l'adaptation et en fait ça on peut
le voir comme une espèce de ces de
l'information dire quelque part c'est de
l'information génétique mais aussi les
interactions c'est un peu plus lointain
morceaux mais bon c'est de l'information
et quand on détruit tout ça on perd
cette information est cette information
en fait elle est vachement utile à nos
sociétés déjà beaucoup de médicaments
qu'on a en fait on les trouve dans la
nature après on apprend à les
synthétiser mais beaucoup de
d'antibiotiques en fait c'est sécrétée
par d'autres micro organismes pour se
défendre de nous les bactéries que leurs
bêtes et du coup il ya plein de faim je
pense
l'immense majorité des cas mmm egypte
est une bêtise sont en fait des
substances naturelles qu'après on
apprend à ses idées on ne va pas les
chercher dans la nature mais on découvre
la nature on apprend la quantité et même
j'ai vu que j'étais la dernière vidéo là
avec techno prob aller sans elle vous
parliez beaucoup de repousser la
vieillesse les gens qui travaillent sur
sa souvent le travail par comment le
vivent à trouver des mécanismes
d'adaptation pour éviter à la sénescence
donc ils vont voir des méduses ils vont
voir des donc en fait quand tu te
détruit la biodiversité tu perds cette
bibliothèque en fait c'est toute cette
possibilité tu perds ce que des
centaines de millions d'années de
tâtonnements ont réussi à produire de
crédible
etc et tu perds des choses qui sont si
ça trouve hyper importante peut-être que
là à cause de ce qu'on aimait comme co2
à cause des fauries conques on coupe on
vient de perdre la solution à la
sénescence
et ça c'est pas impossible ou la
solution au cancer houle et quelques
parents brûle un peu une bibliothèque et
et surtout celle de teck qu'on connaît
même pas en fait c'est on arrive dans un
bain lui aliène on sait que un vaisseau
alien
on s'est calé truc intéressant là dedans
et puis on le détruit sans regarder ce
qu'il ya c'est un peu et du coup quand
j'étais de faire c'est de contrebalancer
un peu ce que je veux dire avec peu trop
a décidé donc pas ce que j'entends
souvent dans le discours environnemental
cette idée qu'une vente énergétique
cette idée que l'énergie est le moteur
de la croissance ou de l'économie et à
l'inversé il ya d'autres discours
d'inquiétant et à michel serres qu un
philosophe écrivain qui a beaucoup écrit
à ce sujet qui qui parle plus de
l'information comme étant le moteur de
du progrès des sociétés ou quelque chose
comme ça en identifiant historiquement
l'invention d'écriture l'invention de
l'imprimerie l'invention des
technologies de calcul des ordinateurs
puis ensuite d'internet est maintenant d
intelligence artificielle et c'est
quelque chose s'est cassé ça me paraît
un aspect important et quand tu parles
d'informations génétiques ou
d'information biotech
en fait c'est servir à de l'information
sera temps de l'énergie et ça sert à
quelque chose qui peut largement
progresser même dans un monde être
logiquement de pétrole bah oui oh oui
auquel je vais essayer de rebondir dans
un monde avec moins de roubles près de
pétrole le problème qu'on aurait c'est
que enfin si on vient de façon plus
générale dans un monde on arrive à
dégager - d'excédent on a une société
moins complexe en fait on peut moins se
permettre de louer une partie de ses
excédents à la production de
connaissances
oui donc ce qu'on fait là comme
vulgarisation ce que font les chercheurs
ce serait
on aurait moins de d'excédent a donné à
ça après voyons y aura autre chose parce
que il ya la notion d' excellents mais
il ya aussi une notion de l'openlab est
d'aller en suisse à la spécialisation
des différents personnes et il reste que
ça pourrait être plus efficace pour
produire de la nourriture que certaines
personnes ne travaillent pas non pas sur
la nourriture mais sur des points de
retraite une information typiquement
prédire je pas le prochain endroit où il
y aura une sécheresse ou ah oui non mais
c'est sûr je dis pas que tout le monde
retournera l'agriculture mais c'est que
des sociétés qui dégage mois d'excédent
parce qu'elles ont moins de ressources
énergétiques peuvent - se consacrer à la
production de connaissances
après la connaissance déjà produite je
suis d'accord qu'elle est là et je suis
pas sûr qu'on puisse opposer sa à la
nécessité d'avoir de l'énergie c'est
comme si c'est comme si je te fais un
plat si je te prépares je sais pas un
risotto aux champignons
tu vas me dire parce qu'il a fait le
placer la recette moi je vais dire non
c'est le céleri et les champignons
inscrit 2 sur les deux sont importants
mais là où je veux en venir c'est que
parlait de la science est exempte de
alves de dance miss appliquée à
l'agriculture c'est que c'est pas tant
une histoire d'excédent c'est une
question de spécialisation et une grosse
partie de comment produire mieux à
manger qui correspond pas à planter des
graines que oui c'est cette connaissance
cette connaissance sur la culture c'est
la connaissance en général d'ailleurs
c'est peut-être un des enjeux de
d'envisager un me font vraiment ainsi
préparé ça serait de sauvegarder au
maximum cette connaissance
ouais tu vois un peu comme dans la
fondation de daisy ma faim là c'est le
cas les frais puisqu'il a lui fondu à
ben en fait en fait l'idée assez c'est
assez intéressant et c'est vraiment à en
parallèle à ce propos en fait dans son
action il ya un espèce de mathématiciens
qui crée une nouvelle discipline qui
s'approche sur les statistiques pour
prédire l'avenir
donc c'est quasiment ce qu'essaye de
faire les colloques et il se rend compte
quand l'effondrement de la civilisation
humaine qui s'est étendue sur tout
l'espace va arriver
que c'est inévitable et en fait ce qu'il
fait c'est que il regarde ce qu'il peut
mettre en place pour que la civilisation
réémerge le plus rapidement possible
après donc en fait ils sauvegardent la
connaissance
il met en place des réserves de
connaissances qui se redéploieront dans
l'univers et ils feront ré émerger une
sirène et du coup c'est vraiment ça
c'est parallèle à sa connaissance
on la gardera et c'est pour ça qu'on va
pas revenir en arrière mais ce qui
permet aujourd'hui à tant de personnes
de vivre aussi bien cdppt le physique
c'est pas la connaissance seul c'est
aussi la connaissance parce que c'est la
façon de les utiliser correctement et
tout mais la connaissance a en elle même
ne nous donne pas à manger et ne donne
pas l'électricité
mais de la même façon je pourrais dire
c'est pas le flux physiques seul parce
que le même si les gens à exploiter le
pétrole fin mois déjà et peut se
demander quand est-ce qu'il pouvait
extraire le pétrole sans connaître la
pause du pétrole utilité j'ai jamais dit
que c'était le flux physiques seul dieu
sait que c'est le flux et la
connaissance tu me dis en gardant la
connaissance je te dis on perd le flux
mais s'il faut les deux tu perds un des
deux tu la pluie tu me dirai si on perd
la connaissance on est aussi dans la
merde je suis d'accord si on perd la
connaissance on n'a plus résonné ou plus
mais le clan hallyday 2,2 s'appuie un
peu plus sur le progrès technologique ça
serait justement d'avoir avec un flux
énergétiques de ressources moindres
exploiter plus de connaissances ou plus
un meilleur traitement de l'information
et pour garantir potentiellement un
niveau de vie qui qui restera ce qu'il
est ou
enfin je sais pas ce qu'il signe un
drame et les pompiers près de tomber sa
section peuvent avoir peuvent permettre
de d'améliorer la qualité de vie mais
c'est quelque chose qui a été pris en
compte et notamment quand on pense à
l'énergie ce qu'on appelle l'efficacité
énergétique en fait leur ai dit pilou de
réussir à faire plus de services avec
moi et ça fait partie de toutes les
adaptations qui sont pas politiques y
sont pas sociales qui sont justes et
même quand on parle de ses pas
rénovation du thermique des bâtiments
c'est ça en fait c'est mieux utiliser ce
qu'on a pour pouvoir diminuer
ce rituel donc c'est une partie du
problème après je pense que et là
j'associerai un gros niveau de
probabilité là dessus c'est que ce sera
pas suffisant ce sera pas suffisant et
tu peux pas jouer seulement sur ce
tableau là qui montre un peu ses limites
même si c'est absolument nécessaire
c'est demain quand on aura moins
d'énergie j'espère qu'on aura eu
l'intelligence entre temps de rénover de
faire la rénovation thermique du bâti
parce que aujourd'hui on a encore les
excédents pour mettre en place ces
changements qui sont des chantiers
colossaux
d'un point de vue industriel c'est pas
quand on aura plus de pétrole dans le
réservoir qu'on pourra tout changer et
tuer tuer ce que je dirai donc ça c'est
des chantiers il faudrait faire
aujourd'hui pour que deux mois quand on
a moins de flux on puisse garder
bah là en l'occurrence des logements
chauffés et du coup il ya des secteurs
où c'est assez évident la rénovation du
bâti c'est évident pour des secteurs
comme la mobilité
c'est très dur de penser garder la
mobilité d'aujourd'hui avec un flux
beaucoup plus faible mais aussi parce
que c'est une des choses qu'on peut se
permettre de faire évoluer ici enfin
quand aura le choix entre manger et
boire avoir un logement chauffé et aux
déplacés tu le déplacera un peu moins
c'est ce qui sautera en premier parce
que c'est les fins pas comment dire il
ya une notion il ya des notions
différentes qui à la fois une toute
l'utilité marginale de nrj dans ce
secteur est moindre
voilà ces vidéos c'est l'idée mais non
mais vraiment le jeu c'est pas du tout
la compréhension scientifique de
l'environnement se fait pas contre la
connaissance pas du tout elle savait pas
contrôler développement de technologies
il ya des gens qui réfléchissent chez
pas à des trucs de capture de co2 mais
ça par exemple c'est un truc qui est qui
après considérablement surévalués dans
les discours parce que c'est beaucoup
plus simple de changer la technologie
que de changer la société ou de changer
moi q logiciel culturel quoi mais parce
que sauf qu'il ya un potentiel à
beaucoup mieux traiter l'information
apparaît dans une vidéo
dans via les technologies dont il ans
certifie ciel et les tons de meilleures
données et on l'a vraiment la vue des
jets passer des trucs qui parler de ça
mais c'est important que le je pense que
le mouvement environnementaliste ou ou
écologiques donne pas mal d'importance à
ça aussi à orienter vers des
technologies de l'information qui
permettront de mieux gérer les flux
énergétiques
mais après comment comment dire en fait
ce que répond le mouvement
environnementaliste
enfin je veux pas parler parce que ce
que je répondrai à ce genre de critique
c'est que ce que moi je vais dire sur la
technologie
ça dépend de deux choses ça dépend de ma
position de mon jugement bayésiens sur
cette question mais cela dépend aussi de
la position des gens autour de moi et
leur jugement là dessus si je vois que
ils font un pari uniquement sur la
technologie et que je pense que ce pari
est débile je vais critiquer ce pari
enfin débile si je le pense pardon c'est
peut-être un peu fort comme mauvais si
je pense qu'on peut pas s'en sortir
qu'avec la technologie je fais
évidemment critiquer mais je vais
critiquer parce que leur position est
trop éloignée de la mienne et qu'ils
accordent trop d'importance ça veut pas
dire que il n'ya rien à faire côté
technologique ça veut dire que ce sont
des approches qui sont à mon avis deux
largement surévalué et pour des raisons
qui sont culturelles en fait qu'ils sont
les fictions et jean vient encore une
fois si je pense que c'est un
affrontement faire un affrontement s'est
il ya luz entre différents discours et
que et que ça c'est le discours
majoritaire parce que ça remet pas en
cause notre vie tous les jours ça remet
pas en cause les usages qu'on a des
choses c'est beaucoup plus rassurant tu
penses que c'est ainsi majoritaire que
ça absolument absolument moi c'est lui
moi je pense que c'est le discours
absolument majorité aujourd'hui dans les
sociétés c'est l'humanité avait toujours
trouver une solution bah oui parce que
sinon on ne serait pas là pour dire on a
toujours trouvé une solution
chez les gens qui comprennent de
problèmes environnementaux les choix là
pic pétrolier ou la limitation des
ressources je pense que ça reste encore
un problème
enfin qu'ils ont encore une perspective
l'énergie point de technologies réseaux
résoudrons le problème date
ça dépend mais pour donner un exemple
concret il ya eu le rapport à ses
récents un noyau 5° du geiq et donc ça
c'est un rapport qui était une question
spécifique c est ce qu on peut tenir
sous les 1 052 normalement les rapports
du giec c'est pas ça c'est une approche
objective du climat là ils répondent à
une question particulière et en fait
c'est tellement à un possible ça ça
voulait dire en fait de de décroître dès
aujourd'hui de 18 % nos émissions de co2
par an donc tu perds un cinquième de ce
quota tous les angles j'exagère à peine
et c'est tellement impossible qu'ils en
sont venus à faire des paris sur des
technologies de stockage donc en fait on
ne peut pas faire les 1,5 donc ce qu'on
va faire c'est qu'on va mettre plus
qu'est-ce qui nous mènerait à 1,5 et
ensuite on va rentrer du carbone dans le
sol
sauf que ces technologies de stockage en
fait on ne déploie pas pour la même
raison que l'on déploie pas d'armes et
de drogue
c'est parce que on les a pas et il ya
quelques expérimentations qui fonctionne
pas très bien qui sont pas du tout à
l'échelle est en fait vu qu'il ya une
nécessité politique à produire un
discours de on tiendra les 1 5
on se met à faire des paris enfin à
sélectionner des théories qui sont qui
sont loin d'être les plus plausibles et
ça c'est un pro pourquoi ya pas pourquoi
on essaye de faire croire à un monde à
1,5
parce que en fait à 1,5 il ya déjà des
gens qui sont des grands perdants du
changement climatique et du coup ils
sont prêts à faire des efforts et à
mettre de l'argent sur la table à faire
évoluer leur société si tout le monde
s'engage à ce qu'on les abandonne pas
quoi donc il faut pouvoir faire croire
qu'il est un monde à 1,5 politiquement
pour que tout le monde montre dans le
bateau mais ce mais ce moment-là 1,5 et
les films et moi moi je alors 2040 je
veux bien parier qu'on n'est pas loin
mais avec 5 2 tu as tu parlé de 2040
pour l'instant sur la territoire actuel
de 1046 1,25 en fait on devrait
décroître radicalement nos émissions
elles n'ont pas cessé d'augmenter
ça fait 20 ans que l'on dit et la
croissance vers le développement durable
l'économie circulaire ça fait 20 ans
qu'elle combine augmenté de 2018 était
plus haut que
2017 2019 sera probablement plus haut
que des u18 donc on n'a même pas
commencé à décroître on n'a même pas
réussi à stabiliser nos émissions
annuelles donc on continue d'ajouter
toujours toujours plus et du coup il ya
des nécessités voilà disent qu il ya eu
des discours plus haut dit que d'autres
et ça s'est un peu fait un tollé entre
guillemets parce que ce qui commence à
se passer c'est que tu as des
climatologues hunte gens pour qui le
métier n'est pas de produire du disco
qui jusque là disait on vous donne les
éléments scientifiques et vous faites ce
que vous jugez bon avec qui sortent et
qui disent faut arrêter de croire à ces
technologies de stockage l'es15 c'est
déjà fini et il faut arrêter de se
mentir
est ce qu'en plus il ya des implications
c'est que 1 si on considère ça qu'on
correctement on peut mettre en place des
actions plus approprié que si on
continue à faire faire n'importe quoi et
deux en fait à un monde où on limite le
à 1,5 degré je pense que économiquement
socialement politiquement c'est
impossible
ça veut dire que 1,5 degré c'est fini ça
veut dire qu'il faut mettre en place des
mécanismes d'adaptation aux impacts
qu'on connaît à 25 degrés on a passé
l'âge en fait où on pouvait se permettre
de juste mitigé et si on reconnaît pas
ça et bien on va pas mettre en place les
mécanismes d'adaptation mais s'invite à
des impacts encore plus fort pour nos
sociétés et mêmes et même dans ce champ
qui est assez scientifique calme et bien
il y à des discours qui sont beaucoup
plus à manger à dégager d'autres pour
des raisons qui ne sont pas du tout
scientifique qui sont que même les
climatologues même les politiques c'est
ce qu'ils veulent croire que c'est ce
qu'ils veulent croire que voir le monde
tel qu'il est c'est extrêmement
extrêmement difficile et à la fois pour
des billets est aussi à cause de la
situation dans laquelle de laquelle on
part et du coup oui mais même dans le
monde scientifique y a il ya des grosses
divergences sur ces questions là il ya
des gens qui font des paris plus ou
moins osée sur sur la technologie et et
après il ya un truc qui fait que
globalement on va pas on va pas
s'avancer on va pas s'arrêter à 1,5 ou à
deux et c'est à mon avis moi c'est ce
que j'appelle le cynisme climatique ne
s'était pas le bon bout
c'est que en fait la majorité les
impacts sont pas portés par surtout des
premiers impacts sont apportées par les
pays les plus polluants tu vois c'est
des régions d'afrique s'est alors c'est
l'inde c'est l'asie du sud est qui est
pas mal touché le pourtour méditerranéen
un peu la californie au kenya le mexique
c'est plus ces régions là et les pays
qui sont les plus gros émetteurs qui
sont pas les premiers touchés et mêmes
et même plus loin les impacts les plus
graves
enfin j'avais regardé un peu les impacts
sanitaires des vagues de chaleur parce
que je connaissais pas trop et j'étais
tombé sur un truc absolument officines
en fait dans un monde à 4,5 degrés il ya
des régions du monde où il ya des
conditions de température et d'humidité
surtout d'humidité ou notre corps humain
ne peut pas se réguler donc en fait il
était dans ces conditions la tumeur de
surchauffe et en fait pour l'instant ça
n'existe pas sur terre les endroits qui
sont très chauds ils sont arides donc tu
peut transpirer ce qui est la façon dont
son corps se refroidit et en fait les
endroits quand ils deviendront très
humide et très chaud tu peux pas
transpiré donc tu perds ce mécanisme qui
permet de baisser sa température
corporelle et c'est des endroits où
alors c'est des modèles on peut dire
c'est un certain etc
mais en tout cas on envisage
sérieusement la possibilité que des
cendres dans ces endroits là en fait
l'environnement devienne réellement
invivable ce qui est quelque chose que
la paraison c'est quelque chose que je
n'aurais pas du tout parier avant de
lire ses études ça paraît inconcevable
et c'est quelque chose qu'il n'a jamais
existé de mémoire d'homme etc c'est
l'asie du sud-est et l'inde a horse et
l'inde mais en fait vu qu il faut que ce
soit 8 c'est l'un des autour de l'indus
et du gange pakistan ce que la date a
beaucoup d'eau et c'est des régions en
fait la période sèche sera plus sèche ou
la période humide sera plus évident donc
tu aura beaucoup d'innovations et ou au
fur et à mesure que les glaciers de
l'himalaya disparaissent on perd la
réserve d'eau pour le printemps et l'été
et ceux des régions l'agriculture
devenir extrêmement difficile et c'est
les régions les plus peuplées du monde
mais ces régions qui sont très loin si
tu lui dis à monsieur madame tout le
monde
voilà vous allez perdre la possibilité
de prendre votre voiture autant
qu'aujourd'hui il faut repenser
l'économie il faut faire des efforts
faut arrêter de prendre l'avion faut
moins consommer de viande faux et qu'est
ce qui se passe si on fait pas ah ben il
est des indiens qui risquent de mourir
et non ça bougera pas ça bougera pas
aussi à cause de ça c'est que si les
gens qui polluent et le plus qui
n'émettait plus de co2 étaient les
premiers touchés et que c'était leur
voisin qui a été emporté par les eaux
nation qui mouraient dans les enfants
dit il y aurait une réaction parce que
et c'est ce qui se passe en août avec
deux problèmes la pollution de l'air
c'est quelque chose où politiquement
c'est plus facile d'agir pourquoi parce
que c'est une pollution locale
instantanée et on arrive à quantifier
bien le nombre de morts du coup on dit
voilà vous faites ça les ca comme
efforts et puis aussi parce que c'est
vers changements technologiques mais si
on sort les voitures des villes et puis
même les asthmatiques etc
les enfants le ressentent le sens
physiquement on sort les voitures des
villes on améliore tout ça c'est
beaucoup plus facile politiquement que
dire vous devez faire ces efforts pour
que des indiens puisse continuer à vivre
et ça c'est vraiment ça c'est un truc
extrêmement cynique de ces évolutions
environnementales tu sais que c'est des
populations qui ne polluent pas qui sont
les plus exposés aux conséquences
le kite prem's et on avait reparlé de
cette de lille où une communauté est
plus ou moins isolé depuis je pas
combien de temps chaque fois qu'il ya un
avion qui passe ils tirent dessus ou une
pirogue est un il y avait un
missionnaire qui est allé il s'était
fait tuer je passe qui a vu cette
actualité j'ai pas une vidéo de dirt eu
beau jeu là dessus si c'est non mais tu
vois le typiquement ils sont à quelques
dizaines de centimètres mètres
d'élévation et en fait lors il va finir
loyers ils verront jamais vu la
civilisation qui avait mille co2 csc
assez cynique et un dernier exemple de
cynisme que j'allais trouver way assez
triste
c'était en fait il est polluant alors
c'est pas que l'on climatique ce coup ci
même s'ils ont aussi être touchés par le
changement climatique et les polluants
qu'on appelle les polluants organiques
persistants mousse et des pesticides
c'est des résidus de combustion c'est
des trucs qu'on utilise pour éviter que
nos canapés prennent feu par exemple est
en fait ces trucs là c'est toxique à
certaines doses et le problème c'est que
ces résistants donc une fois que s'est
répandue l'environnement ça tient assez
longtemps et il ya un phénomène de
bioaccumulation on appelle ça en fait ça
c'est des éléments une autre de la
particularité c'est que il préfère les
milieux organique à l'eau donc en fait
si tu mets d'huile de l'eau et vont se
retrouver dans lui
ce qui fait que quand ils sont absorbés
par un être vivant ils vont se fixer
dans les graisses ou dans les tissus
donc en fait au fur et à mesure nous on
est exposé tout le temps c'est pas très
grave
on a toujours un peu dans le doute un
jour un peu si c'est pas des doses
énormes c'est pas grave et ça se fixe
dans les êtres vivants et ce qui fait
que tu as une accumulation le long de la
chaîne alimentaire
tu vois un second il mange plein plein
de petits poissons crevettes il avait
explosé à plein de ces trucs il valait
ibal et les fixer et ça va s'accumuler
dans son organisme et le phoque qui
mangent les seconds je sais quand je
connais pas bien mais chaîne alimentaire
marine
eh bien il va en accumuler encore plus
il y avait un exemple en norvège il
avait un problème et une espèces de
canards et comprenait pas pourquoi il
trouvait toujours les femelles mortes et
pas les mâles et souvent au printemps et
en fait c'est parce que elle accumulait
sur un temps très long dans leur graisse
des quantités donc la quantité dans le
sang était pas énorme mais ça se fixer
dans la grèce donc c'était relativement
inerte et au printemps qu'elle devait
faire leurs oeufs et bien le brûler
toutes leurs graisses d'un coup pour
avoir d'énergie et du coup libéré d'un
coup ces toxines accumulées sur
longtemps et du coup le taux dans le
sens de venir relever s'habituer et en
fait pour des raisons de circulation
atmosphérique et océanique
ça a tendance à migrer vers les pôles
c'est surtout émis dans l'hémisphère
nord donc ça a tendance à migrer vers le
pôle nord et au pôle nord il ya des
eskimos qui se nourrissent bat pas trop
de légumes et de fruits parce que ça
pousse pas donc qui se nourrissent que
d'animaux et d'animaux assez haut dans
la chaîne alimentaire
donc ils se retrouvent sur exposé à ces
quantités et il ya des scientifiques qui
ont été voir ça et qui ont regardé les
quantités dans le lait maternel est en
fait les quantités étaient tellement
énorme que c'est des produits qui aurait
était impropre à la consommation humaine
tu vois si si tu trouvé ces trucs là
dans du lait de supermarchés du les
bâches et bien on pourrait pas les
vendre parce que les quantités sont trop
élevés donc là encore c'est les
civilisations faire des situations des
ouïes de stylisation je suis pas si
c'est le bon mode des sociétés humaines
qui n'ont jamais émis ces choses là et
qu'ils sont plus exposés que nous à nos
émissions en fait donc encore un espèce
de cynisme je sais pas si c'est utile
comme anecdote mais je trouve ça assez
impressionnant et puis le football parce
que leur milieu naturel
enfin le milieu dans lequel ils sont
développées il est un peu près condamné
je pense
rapaces et c'est sûr que ça ça pose des
problèmes assez c'est horrible les âges
présence ouais c'est des gros problème
éthique quand même parce que ouais c'est
pour ça que le des problèmes comme la
pollution de l'air par exemple à une
forme de justice entre guillemets c'est
ceux qui émettent qui sont exposées ou
qui sont dans le voisinage une qui peut
y faire quelque chose des problèmes à
longue distance comme ça c'est c'est dur
il ya aussi une question de temporalité
et ça c'est un truc qui manque un peu
sur sur ta chaîne sur celle de monsieur
fils et des aspects philosophiques mais
sur la temporalité tu vois par exemple
en fait le pétrole c'est vraiment une
substance incroyable quand on y pense
je vais beaucoup critiqués parce qu'on
parle de changement climatique mais en
fait la densité énergétique de ce truc
là est absolument incroyable et c'est
une substance d'en avoir beaucoup de mal
à se passer et je pense qu'on lui doit
beaucoup de ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
en plus des connaissances je dis pas que
tu aies de l'ensemble et du coup
aujourd'hui si j'utilise un litre de
pétrole pour faire du karting
est-ce que c'est moral en sachant que
peut-être que celui de pétrole sera
vital à quelqu'un demain dans une
ambiance et ça c'est une problématique
qui se pose souvent dans l'environnement
c'est la question de la temporalité
surtout quand tu considères
l'utilisation de ressources non
renouvelables qui et quelle est notre
droit de taper dans les ressources
fossiles en en privant les les sociétés
suivantes
alors ça c'est des questions je suis pas
du tout inquiet il ya des gens qui
considèrent qu' il faudrait remplacer
par un capital équivalent et c'est
extrêmement compliqué et justement je
suis parti et là dessus donc ça me
plairait vraiment d'avoir du contenu qui
aborde ces questions c'est quand même
déçu et passent pas exactement ce sujet
qu'on aborde mais souvent il n'est
question qui se pose c'est son appel de
prendre du facteur de ce compte
c'est à quel point on donne de
l'importance aux futurs ou également à
ce qui est distante géographiquement
ouais
mais ça c'est hyper compliqué d'y penser
je pense que c'est une grosse partie du
problème
en fait ces lieux si la civilisation si
les sociétés humaines se penser comme un
tout elle avait à gérer différemment
enfin ça demanderait d'avoir une
connaissance aussi beaucoup plus et tu
penses que s'ils avaient pas le pétrole
les civilisations ont été complètement
différente vous prendrez été très
attardé je pense qu'ils auraient pas eu
les ressources possibles
ouais absolument parce que ça commençait
à être exploités dans des vidéos au
deuxième siècle non en allant bien avant
la révolution industrielle je sais pas
comment ça commence mais l'exploitation
en fait je pense que la révolution
industrielle ouais c'est le charbon est
en fait je pense qu'on fait démarrer sa
l'essor de notre période moderne
rémy 750 mille huit cents et c'est un
truc intéressant d'ailleurs c'est en
fait ça ça a commencé il ya déjà des
sociétés qui exploitait un peu des
ressources disponibles en surface il
c'est arrivé si tu avais du charbon qui
a hébergé un endroit où ou de la tourbe
qui est un des trucs pourris dans la
terre on peut voir ça comme du charbon
primordiale je sais pas trop donc ya
déjà des sociétés qui exploitent et ces
choses là qui était pas vraiment
renouvelables et pareil pour des
ressources humaines mais vraiment
l'explosion de l'utilisation des
ressources fossiles
c'est quand il ya un ingénieur un peu
malins qui a fait en fait une pompe pour
une vie des lots qui s'engouffrait dans
les mines de charbon c'est ce qui nous a
permis d'aller chercher le charbon dans
le sol en angleterre et ça ça a été un
des premiers trucs étudier et on parlait
tout à l'heure de l'efficacité
énergétique et souvent ce qu'on va te
répondre à ça c'est l'effet rebond
je sais pas si tu as déjà entendu et
vous apparaît dans une vidéo des
chansons à huy exact exact exact est en
fait l'effet rebond le premier qu'on a
regardé si tu es là dessus et justement
c'est que ces machines on s'est dit ah
ben voilà on sort du charbon on en met
dans les machines ça on consomme
beaucoup on va faire en sorte que elle
consomme moins de charbon comme ça on
économisera du charbon donc on les a
rendus plus en plus efficaces et qu'est
ce qui s'est passé eh ben on a utilisé
de plus en plus de machines est en fait
ces machines à vapeur qu'on l'utilisé
pour sortir l'eau des mines ça s'est
généralisée à toute l'économie
la fée lectra on a fait des usines et
c'est parce qu'on a rendu ces machines
très efficace et du coup on a consommé
plus de charbon in fine et parce qu'on
les rendant plus efficace on n'a plus
beaucoup plus les utiliser mais alors
faut 40 a joué un rôle très important de
cécile quand même une lecture très
énergétiques de l'histoire des
civilisations
je renvoie à ce que disait la confiance
de michel serres sur le traitement de
l'information si on regarde le
traitement d'informations comme étant de
quelque chose d'important dans
l'histoire des civilisations
il ya moyen d'avoir un narratif
similaires j'ai envie dire je sais pas
hier le joueur on a eu l'écriture et
commencer à voir une exposition des
civilisations il voit on a eu à
l'imprimé démocratisation de la
connaissance et et ça a conduit au
capitalisme et tout ça le jour où on a
commencé à voir des machines à calculer
et puis après internet
et puis l'intelligence artificielle
vieillit à chaque fois des boum comme
cela ses poèmes et c'est une co
évolution
c'est une coalition je dis pas que la
connaissance à apa son rôle mais mais
pour moi il n'y aurait pas eu le charbon
il n'y aurait pas eu cette production de
connaissances de connaissances je pense
qu'il y aura eu parce qu'il ya des
failles à pas mal de parents plus le
fait d'avoir l'écriture sacrément changé
beaucoup de choses dans la manière de
fonctionner des civilisations se permet
d'avoir des textes de loi se permet
d'avoir des structures en terme
d'organisation
cependant avoir des textes religieux
aussi qui perdure
le fait d'avoir l'imprimé il ya
complètement bouleversé la
démocratisation des textes 50 due à des
gens qui apprennent à lire qui après
avoir pensé un peu d'eux-mêmes va lancer
leurs propres projets et donc il ya un
argument pour dire que ça c'était un
petit peu les premières briques ensuite
en venir insiste m
plus décentralisée avec la
spécialisation chacun qui travaille à sa
manière et après le fait d'avoir des
systèmes d'information via internet où
on a l'information accès facilement well
monde mais pas du doigt car le narratif
aussi qui me semble ouais c'est ça qui
m'intéresse ce n'est pas le cas c'est
pas tellement le narratif c'est en fait
que ce que tf1 était en train de me dire
il n'y aurait pas eu imprimerie on
n'aurait pas eu le livre je suis en
train de te dire on aurait pas de bois
on aurait pas de papiers on aurait pas
de livre c'est pas exclusifs comme comme
façon de voir les choses c'est la
combinaison des deux sauf que c'est la
combinaison des deux d'ailleurs un
excellent livre à lire même si le titre
fait un peu peur c'est cataclysme je
sais pas si tu vois ce que c'est c'est
un des livres les plus intéressants que
j'ai lu moi c'est un livre d'un mec qui
s'appelle laurent testo et en fait c'est
la même logique
or la fin je suis un peu plus mitigé
mais mais l'essentiel est qu'un
excellent c'est la même logique que
sapiens sauf que les aurait gardées
l'évolution des idées y regarde comment
les sociétés humaines ont influé sur
l'environnement et comment
l'environnement a influé sur les
sociétés humaines
mais autant l'on est vraiment c'est très
très bien ce que je pensais une frange
un peu nouvelle de l'histoire et de
pessah de l'histoire environnementale
ces excellents ailleurs et du coup c'est
tu peux voir que les connaissances mais
il ya des conditions environnementales
et lui typiquement humain narratif
qu'autour des conditions
environnementales
donc la question ce n'est pas tellement
le narratif si on peut faire les deux
s'est sans doute que les deux événements
sont pertinents et d'ailleurs ce qui est
assez marrant c'est que en fait c'est un
changement climatique qui a qui a
provoqué notre espèce
parce que c'est une désertification
d'une partie de l'afrique qui a remplacé
dès des forêts primaires par des savanes
et on a dû se redresser parce que il y
avait plus d'arbres donc les salles
aussi way est pareil l'agriculture il ya
beaucoup de gens qui considèrent donc
dont moi c'est plutôt mon et films coup
qu'en fait c'est rendu possible et c'est
possible que
dans un climat stable en particulier
quand tu l'as fait évoluer au début tu
as d'état les rendements qu'ils sont
tous pourris
les premiers agriculteurs étaient des
gens assez malheureux il ya dirty
biologique un appareil de comptage et
l'api rural du métier et du coup au
début quand à des rendements tout pourri
et tu sais tu as besoin d'avoir un
climat qui est stable d'une année sur
l'autre qui est très utile pour voir
qu'à l'été récolte au bon moment pour
être sûr de récolter quelque chose sinon
on fait les sociétés qui a été dans un
moment trop instables ou trop sensible
elles sont probablement disparu pendant
cette phase là parce que d'une année sur
l'autre les avait des différences de
récolte est en fait l'holocène les
derniers douze mille ans c'est un
endroit où le climat a été extrêmement
stable il ya des chercheurs d'ailleurs
qui pense que c'est en partie dû à
l'activité humaine de nos ancêtres
ça s'était rendu stable ouais c'était
l'hypothèse rudiments parce qu'en fait
quand tu regardes les autres
interglaciaire normalement ça monte ou
en température sortie de périodes
glaciaires et ça redescend direct il n'y
a pas de plateau comme on a connu une
eau pendant 12 millions et du coup il ya
des gens qui se posent des questions sur
ce plateau est une hypothèse un lâche
parle pas du tout de choses consensuel
je ne pense pas c'est que ce soit en
partie à cause des sociétés humaines et
en fait les sociétés humaines
elles ont joué sur deux tableaux
importants là dessus c'est que l on fait
disparaître les grands mammifères là
donc je parlais et çà çà çà çà un impact
énorme sur la végétation
parce que c'est celle de la fameuse
chasse a vu la vidéo sur le parc de
yellowstone où les loups ou les requins
produisent les louves et du coup il
réintroduire les loups sa chasse les
trucs qui mangeait au bord des cours
d'eau dont médias les fourrés qui
repousse parce que il chasse le gibier
qui mangeait qui pousse et en fait quand
tu vires des grands mammifères comme ça
tu as un énorme impact sur le couvert
végétal et un autre qui a beaucoup joué
c'est que les premières cultures qui ont
fait de la culture où même les premiers
chasseurs ils avaient recours à des
bruits massif soit pour fertiliser les
sols soit pour rabattre le gibier est en
fait les régions entières de la terre
qui ont été brûlés à ce temps voilà est
en fait dès que tu touches un peu
couvert où tu brûles etc
ça joue sur le sérieux et il peut y
avoir des effets stabilisation c'est pas
du tout consensuel mais il ya des gens
qui se pose sincèrement la question de
l'impact des premières civilisations
ce qui change un peu des discours le mal
est né avec le capitalisme et et
l'industrie
et même quand on parle d'ailleurs des
des premières grandes disparition de là
à l'époque en fait nos ancêtres ils ont
fait disparaître des roumains y faire il
était assez peu aux outils utilisés pour
faire disparaître chez pathé espèce de
sauterelle parce qu'il aurait fallu tous
les dés seraient les écraser un terme là
nous on est mieux outillé avec leur en
changeant radicalement l'usagé des sols
et avec certains molécules chimiques on
peut quand même faire disparaître des
petites espèces c'est la grande
innovation mais en tout cas pour les
gros espèces c'est assez impressionnant
si tu regardes l'extinction de l'eau
saine je pense tu peux tomber dessus
c'est assez impressionnant de voir ces
des espèces qu'on n'imagine pas et en
fait même chez nous quand tu regardes
ses les peintures sur les grottes de
lascaux et compagnie bayh avait dîné
rhinocéros il y avait des lions y avait
des sources
il y avait des espèces de singes en
allemagne je crois enfin c'était un truc
assez ouf
et il y avait les lots rock ou le rock
ça c'est que moi je sais pas comment
dire que c'est du rock c'est l'ancêtre
des vaches qu'on a aujourd'hui qui a
disparu qui était un énorme vaches qui
l'ayant le choix est plus gros que nos
taureaux qui avait des grosses cornes et
on l'a fait disparaître des gens qui ont
essayé de reconstituer en faisant je
sais pas comment dire de la bac
évolution donc en fait en croisant des
espèces qui existent aujourd'hui pour
essayer de reconstituer le génome de le
rock ils ont essayé de recréer un drop
comme ça que ça marche assez mal c'est à
s'éloigner je pense si on en croit les
les peintures parce que il a disparu je
crois en 16 cents et les boîtes donc
c'est assez récent donc on a de la
description des romains où l'image
donc ça a l'air assez éloignée mais je
trouvais ça rigolo comme un génie mais
bon jeu mais là on est un peu du sujet
non mais je suis d'accord avec toi la
connaissance joue un rôle mais pour moi
alors à la fois elle permet d'exploiter
de nouvelles ressources
mais elle est aussi permise par par ces
flux de matériaux elle est permise par
mieux sa vie que climatique elle est
permise par la production des clients
qui permet aux sociétés inquiet des gens
qui cherchent un que tu regardes les
grands penseurs les grands auteurs de
même d'oeil à 300 400 ans
c'était des gens qui étaient riches
parce que c'étaient les seuls qui
pouvaient se permettre de passer leur
vie à faire ma recherche
c'est des gens souvent qu'il
atterrissait sur un un pactole et du
coup il n'avait pas passé leur vie aux
champs parce que doutes levés à leur
place et quelque part c'est une chance
mais ça se trouve il y avait plein de
paysans qui sont morts de récents
l'époque s'il était né à cet endroit là
on aurait des connaissances différentes
en plus ou en moins bien
et du coup aussi insisté sur cet
argument revient encore avec cette
histoire de spécialisation qui ne sont
pas nécessairement liés à à l'excédent
c'est à dire que si les gens sont
capables de se spécialiser et vont
peut-être se rendre compte que six ils
font la tâche où ils sont très très bons
ils pourront échanger sa contre notre
quelqu'un qui fait l'agriculture à côté
que abc je comprends je m'en rends pas
trop ce que ça veut dire parce que moi
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est pas
une critique de la spécialisation au
contraire je pense qu'on en est là parce
qu'on est spécialisée et c'est très bien
mais c'est plutôt que tu vois si si si
un agriculteur en arriver à nourrir que
lui on serait tous adultes en fait alors
si on a vu bornes en effet sont invités
tous ces agriculteurs ce serait le cas
mais même si on était tous habitants
agriculteurs mois déjà je pense que
l'agriculteur des périodes sont ya rien
à faire et il faut juste attendre et
même si on était tous agriculteurs on se
spécialisera est quand même sur
certaines parties surtout à partir du
moment où on arrive à trouver des moyens
de se spécialiser avoir des systèmes de
de commerce de la spécialisation n'est
pas une conséquence du fait d'avoir une
situation d'abondance non d'accord je
suis d'accord avec toi mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que on a des besoins
primordiaux en termes de haut en termes
d'adaptation en terme de nourriture et
en fait pendant une grande partie de
l'humanité
les excédents qui ont dégagé était
tellement faible que la majorité de la
population était allouée à produire
c'est bien là et aujourd'hui en fait les
excédents sont tellement importants que
au final ce qui prouve un qui s'occupe
ne s'est pas de de l'eau de l'énergie de
la nourriture et de conte sur les
bâtiments c'est même plus une majeure
partie de la population
ouais mais s'il est aussi une histoire
de spécialisation qui fait que
aujourd'hui si je regarde quelle est la
manière dont je peux contribuer plus
efficacement la société vu les
compétences que j'ai ce sera
probablement pas en étant exécuteur
moi-même d'accord même si enfin mais je
ne vois pas en quoi c'est qu'on
travaille que ce que je dis c'est pour
dire que le fait d'avoir du temps pour
réfléchir pas typiquement pour diriger
je vais pas prendre des décisions
compliquées ou comprendre analyser faire
des analyses quoi ça peut être un besoin
qui n'est même dans une situation sans
abondance et qu'ils soient récompensés
parce que si c'est tout que plus
efficace offensivement 6,6 et des
analyses pour prédire les zones de
sécheresse année prochaine et que ça va
en bossant j'arrive à les prédire parce
que pas le cas du côté du tout le coup
mais imaginons que ça soit le cas je
serais quand même un fou serait quand
même à faire ça même dans une situation
où on manquerait à manger quoi
d'accord je ne suis pas si je suis clair
mais c'est vrai que la spécialisation à
ce moment là c'est ici il manque à
manger en fait on perdrait des
agriculteurs avant de te perdre toi
parce que le plus important pour la
haute cote globale si j'arriverai faire
ce trajet aujourd'hui c'est d'ailleurs
pris des noms mais je peux comprendre
c'est assez logique mais mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que quand même
globalement tu regardes sur l'échelle de
quelques siècles les excédents de la
production primaire qui nous est
nécessaire à atouts sont quand même
incroyablement augmenté tu as le fc
saint-louis le personne que peut nourrir
un agriculteur le nombre de personnes
que s'occuper les gens qu'ils
assainissent l'eau etc
ça va énormément augmenter et c'est ce
qui permet cette spécialisation qu'on a
aujourd'hui
et quelque part se préoccuper des
problèmes environnementaux c'est vouloir
sauvegarder ça peut-être que je le fais
aussi comment de façon égoïste parce que
moi je n'ai pas construit des maisons je
sais pas faire à manger je sais pas
tenir un réseau électrique donc je
préférerais qu'on reste dans une société
relativement complexe où on peut me
trouver une utilité départ en pratique
dans cet environnement complexe
d'aujourd'hui
enfin je pense que tu as beaucoup plus
d'utilité en faisant tâche et youtube
que nous allons planter des choux ouais
je suis d'accord mais mais si ces
surplus décroissent je virais pas les
résultats on est vrai moi parce que je
suis fière les agriculteurs je meurs de
faim tu es en fait c'est un peu
l'illusion les gens qui sont au delà qui
ramid aujourd'hui entre guillemets qu'on
considère comme l'élite j'ai
l'impression qu'ils se rendent pas
compte que le haut de la pyramide elle
est là parce qu'il ya tous les blocs en
dessous du top je suis passé je pense
que ça se discute parce que si tu es
capable de faciliter les processus des
travailleurs un typiquement un des trucs
dedans et isner dont ils parlent souvent
donc tu y vas en avoir c'est ce podcast
qui se posent des questions de la
tribune efficace et sûre comment sont
elles sont les meilleures actions
entreprendre mettant pas mal d'épisodes
sur va faire la recherche dans tel
domaine et des trucs qui serait
l'équivalent d'être agriculteur j'en ai
dit assez des trucs vraiment sur le
terrain où on fait des trucs mais ce que
dit ti talonneur c'est qu'en fait ce qui
manque le plus ce sont les organisations
triste comme committee centers
c'est juste des managers qui facilite le
travail des gens sur le terrain des
justes des coordinateurs ok je comprends
mais pou pour moi je ok mais même dans
une situation de la boîte ils pourraient
avoir besoin d'un manager d'agriculteurs
dire ok je vais préciser un peu mon truc
du coup donc moi ça je les inclus ray
directement dans la culture toi si tu
veux je regarde le surplus dégagés par
les process d la culture le surplus
dégagés par les process du bâtiment et
ça inclut à la fois les gens sur le
terrain
et puis les les gens qui les aident en
développant des nouvelles plantes etc
mais après tu peux aider de façon assez
direct parce que peut-être que les
managers de manager ou des reprises
organisation pour essayer de regrouper
les bonnes idées de la gauche à droite
et puis le donc le mec qui gère la
conférence qui réunit les managers
d'agriculteurs est-ce qu'ils travaillent
encore dans l'agriculture
je sais pas mais mais tu vois ce que je
veux dire c'est un peu la notion c'est
un peu la notion de taux de retour
énergétique aussi c'est que tu vas tu
vois ce que veut dire c'est pas parce
que le nom en manque de nourriture que
tout le monde doit produire à ne manger
que sa crise
ouais non je comprend mais mais si
globalement ces processus
les dégage moins de surplus ça fait que
tu dois être l agence et à la société en
conséquence
et d'ailleurs c'est l'évolution inverse
ce qu'on a vu jusque là au fur et à
mesure que l'agriculture avait besoin de
moins de bras les gens se déplacer vers
les villes est allé à l'usiné au fur et
à mesure que les usines s'automatiser le
tertiaire apparu est en fait au fur et à
mesure que ces processus les plus
primaires de nos sociétés devenez plus
efficace on à dégager du temps libre des
ressources cours des choses beaucoup
toujours plus complexes j'ai du mal à
nous à le voir autrement
enfin les imaginant que dans des
situations où morgan de femmes meurent
de faim a vraiment besoin de produire à
manger nous on est beaucoup et on n'a
pas tous les mêmes expertises
il y en a qui sont très bons pour tenter
labourer la terre et comprennent très
bien tout ça et il y en a d'autres qui
sont meilleures fonctions moins bons
pour ça mais bah ils sont peut-être
meilleur en relations humaines
même les ont pas besoin d'être meilleur
en relations humaines s'ils sont moins
bons ils peuvent labourer les terres ils
peuvent enfin c'est l'histoire de ça
s'appelle le il suffit avec une vidéo
dessus j'espère retrouver les avantages
compétitifs
ses avantages compétitifs quand on parle
quand il faut les avantages comparatifs
c'est l'histoire des avantages
comparatifs que moi non je comprends
conduisent à des spécialisations même si
tu es moins bon
pourvu que les autres sont meilleurs que
toi vraiment meilleur que toi pour le
faire de produire à manger tu peux
trouver une utilité qui m'aiment pas
d'en reproduire à montgermont situation
il faut quoi
oui je comprend mais mais ça changera à
la tendance de fond qui a su ce que tu
disais que le fait qu'on ait le temps de
réfléchir
c'est un luxe du à l'abondance ça me
paraît pas si clair c'est ce passé
immédiat il ya besoin de gens qui qu'ils
réfléchissent eux mêmes en production
même si on était en situation où il
fallait juste produire à manger sans
doute mais on est tous autant de temps à
réfléchir je pense que c'est
relativement nouveau
je fabrique je pense mais pas d'en avoir
autant de temps à réfléchir mais oui je
pense qu'on a eu la chance de faire un
métier où on a vraiment bien et je pense
que des gens nous envient pour ça et ça
car on avait tu me demandais que faire
je n'avais pas tout à fait finie la
dirai donc il y avait la perception
politique et que parce que pour vous
mettre en place des régulations et parce
qu'il est un des premiers trucs dans que
faire et c'est vrai nous vous promettez
je pense que c'est hyper important de
réfléchir un peu tout ça est de
comprendre aujourd'hui sur quoi repose
notre mode de vie est en fait ne pas
considérer ça comme acquis et il ya
effectivement l'idée de la
spécialisation économique de ce conte
font les autres acteurs et il ya aussi
l'idée de voir les flux physiques en
dessous de voir les flux d'énergie et
tweed et d'avoir conscience de ça tu
vois un exemple que tu disais qu'ils
disaient prendre des douches l'ongle
avec très grave parce qu'il ya pas mal
d'eau en fait le problème de la douche
c'est pas tellement
enfin ça dépend des environs les
problèmes que ces lots mais c'est aussi
qu'il faut pas mal d'énergie pour
chauffer de local et s'assurer c'est des
choses qui ne s'est pas forcément
intuitif l'énergie qu'on utilise
l'électricité dont a besoin un frigo le
réseau électrique je pense que c'est un
des plus bel objet technique de
l'humanité même si c'est
je pense que beaucoup de gens le méprise
un peu houleux connaissent peu mais
quand tu vois la taille que c'est qu'il
faut toujours que la production soit
égal à la consommation et où c'est assez
incroyable comme comme objet technique
d'ailleurs ces lois est un des plus
grands avec l'internet vu que s'est
connecté maintenant sur des grandes
distances et donc je pense que vraiment
une des premières étapes c'est de se
renseigner et de voir tout ça et quand
on regarde ça c'est à deux effets là je
vais parler pour moi c'est mon opinion
1 on se rend compte que c'est pas
nécessairement acquis et ça c'est
important parce que je pense que les
choses qu'on considère comme acquis on a
tendance à les perdre
donc ça fait un peu facebook de merde
mais on se rend compte des choses qu'on
a quand les perds tu as un peu la
logique est en fait ça serait dommage
d'attendre de les perdre pour se rendre
compte de ce seuil c'est important tissu
et donc voilà faut se rendre compte en
fait que ça c'est incroyable et qu'il
faut le garder si on dit si tu vas donc
passé il ya deux mille ans étudie je
rentre chez moi j'appuie sur un bouton
la lumière s'allume tu fais de la magie
qui l'a en fait notre vie de tous les
jours d'aujourd'hui c'est de la magie
pour il ya quelques siècles
et ça ça serait pas mal de le garder
parce que c'est quelque chose que
j'apprécie d'être au chaud au calme de
pouvoir jouer un peu à l'ordinateur vous
pouvoir avoir la lumière de pouvoir lire
le soir d'avoir un livre passionnant à
lire c'est quand même des choses
vachement bien et en fait faudrait pas
sous focus toujours sur ce qu'on
pourrait avoir en plus tu vas faudrait
pas qu'à courir après le superflu en
perles inutile pour finir en un slogan
facebook et deuxième aspect et ça c'est
mon opinion personnelle ça va faire un
peu oublier peut-être c'est qu'en fait
quand tu te rends compte de ça tu
viennes quelque chose c'est que tu
apprécies beaucoup beaucoup plus tout ça
je pense que j'apprécie plus que
beaucoup de mes contemporains
le fait d'avoir la lumière d'avoir une
pièce chauffée d'avoir un frigo
enfin je sais que ça peut paraître bête
mais en vrai voilà j'essaie de manger
local et saison par exemple
j'essaye dans ce match facile je suis
pas non plus super attention ne lit pas
toutes les étiquettes mais je prends pas
dé fraises en décembre et ben quand j'ai
des fraises en avril mais ça va pas trop
tarder chance je les apprécie beaucoup
plus que la plupart des landes quant au
parrain qui en mange toute l'année parce
que je les ai attendus parce que je sais
que c'est bon moment parce que
honnêtement quand tu les prends de
saison il faut quand même meilleur que
quand elles sont mûri sous serres
chauffées
et je pense qu'il ya plein de choses
dans ma vie de tous les jours que
j'apprécie beaucoup plus que beaucoup de
gens quand je dois attendre le train
parce qu'il a un quart d'heure de retard
je ne dis pas un quart d'heure et ça
fait chier parce que souvent aidé à
l'heure et surtout parce que c'est
incroyable de là je suis souvent en
verve en deux heures même pas je peux
être à paris ça va hyper vite je suis au
chaud à 6 avec internet je vais
continuer à travailler sur mes scripts
enfin et honnêtement je pense que me
rendre compte en fait de la fragilité du
système et qu'on peut perdre tout ça ça
me permet de beaucoup plus cela
précipite je pense que c'est moi je suis
d'accord donc apprenons à apprécier ce
qu'on a et du coup que faire de plus bas
moi ma mission et j'en suis convaincu
c'est un peu celle que fait sur youtube
donc ses lâchetés nique avec tête un
billet c'est que faut parler tout ça
parce que si on veut une sortie par le
haut entre guillemets une sortie
ensemble démocratique sans imposer des
choses que les gens ne comprennent pas
il faut expliquer les tenants et les
aboutissants il faut expliquer ce qu'on
sait il faut expliquer les conséquences
et là comment disais je pense que si
l'affrontement est et entre les discours
c'est aussi un peu mon rôle de lutter
contre des discours qui serait moi je
m'attaque surtout à des disques office
juste faux c'est même pas une histoire
d'opinion ce que racontent les climato
sceptiques dans la vidéo que j'attaque
cdc des choses qui sont fausses et les
fois qu'ils sont des manipulations
volontaire des fois qu'ils sont des
erreurs mais qui sont fausses et
honnêtement quand je commence à regarder
des discours chez pas de futurologue
j'ai lu rifkin par exemple je suis en
train de lire idrissa berkane qui est le
livre le pire que j'ai vu de ma vie chez
même pas si j'irai au bout c'est
absolument insupportable
à lire j'ai je comprends même pas que
c'est justement j'ai pas lu mais tu
donnes envie mais c'est mais c'est une
horreur c'est ce qui est sûr en fait
j'ai c'est assez intéressant parce que
je pense qu'il attire les gens parce
qu'il débite des anecdotes
en fait il a beaucoup de culture
générale de connaissance réelle
articulaires mais si tu enlèves ça si tu
regardes la structure du raisonnement il
ya soit rien soif ou quoi c'est ca c'est
ouf c'est ta les feuilles de l'arbre
enlève les feuilles a pas d'arbres en
fait
et quand je lis ces trucs là qui sont
des discours un peu
rifkin ces voix là on va s'en sortir
troisième révolution on va s'en sortir
avec que des choses immatérielles donc
on va continuer à faire de la croissance
sans que c'est une incidence sur les
flux tu lis ça les erreurs sont
extrêmement lisible
en fait j'ai lu un vrai s'appelle le
coût marginal nul et dit bah voilà on
prend un livre électronique par exemple
eh ben si on en fait des copies
le coût marginal donc le coût pour
produire une copie de ce livre il est
pratiquement nul
il faut quelques serveurs il faut que
l'envoyé etc mais c'est pratiquement nul
et du coup on est dans une société où
produire un élément supplémentaire a pas
de coup de main qu'on perd un peu la
matérialité et les coccinelles et après
il fait le même raisonnement sur les
éoliennes
donc tu te plantes ton d'éoliennes et
après le kilowatt heure suivant
l'éolienne est là donc ça coûte rien
tueur sauf que dans un ingénieur il
réfléchit à gaza et d'y monter au yen
elle dure tant de temps elle va fournir
tant d'électricité en tout le coût total
investissement en réparation
démantèlement et s'étend donc même coup
par kilowattheure lévisien parloter g
est en fait en supprimant complètement
le coût initial
eh bien il fait croire que le
renouvelable permet un poulet un coût
marginal moins d'énergie ce qui est
globalement une astuce d'économistes
pour pour nier toutes les contraintes
environnementales ils finissent toujours
par leur modèle où il n'ya pas de
problème l'environnement ils finissent
par le modèle à part avoir soit un coût
marginal mines d'énergie soit une
énergie propre et infini enfin et c'est
toujours l'énergie 1 qu'il faut rayer
peint souvent dans ses modèles c'est
pour ça aussi
et du coup quand tu regardes ses
discours se rend compte que ses discours
ils sont facilement critiquable et la
plupart des gens ne sont pas outillés et
on peut pas du tout la reprocher pour
pour voir où est le problème et en plus
il ya un billet c'est que si tu veux
croire ça tu vas un peu a b c tt défense
intellectuelle la tuer même françois
gervais le dernier climato sceptiques
que j'ai critiqué je pense que c'est pas
forcément quelqu'un qui le fait
sciemment mais mais quand tu vois il a
un niveau de suspicion extrême envers
les trucs du changement climatique
anthropique
bon il finit en finale par au juste se
retrouver avec césar lui mais quand il
ya des choses dans son camp là il a
aucune suspicion et il se met en fête à
reprendre les arguments ou à partager
les choses qui viennent de sources
traitement douteuses parce qu'il ya un
billet tu as et pareil pour ses discours
si tu ne croire que à l'avenir tu auras
une économie qui va continuer à croître
à l'infini ben si quelqu'un de 10 à qui
tu vas pas trop vérifier ce qu'ils
racontent et du coup je pense que moi je
dois produire un discours factuel défaut
aussi je fasse attention au discours que
produisent les autres et quand il ya des
notions un peu technique je peux arriver
en ce moment là et est ce que j'envisage
peut-être un jour et ce qu'il faudrait
faire parce que je pense que c'est
vraiment une question d'évolution aussi
des fictions une question d'évolution
culturel c'est de créer du discours pour
l'instant ce que font beaucoup les
scientifiques c'est dire on a tous ces
éléments et ensuite on laisse à d'autres
la possibilité de créer des discours
alors ça peut être des journalistes et
des politiques ça peut être des gens qui
font la science fiction ou des romans
d'anticipation et moi je me dis un jour
peut-être il faudrait qu'ils fassent des
romans d'anticipation et c'est là que
j'aurais plus d'impact en permettant de
mettre des images sur ce qui peut
advenir ou ski sur ce qu'il est en train
d'arriver que en expliquant des faits
peut-être que c'est ça auquel notre
cerveau de sapiens pas tellement
outillés et le plus sensible peut-être
que c'est là que j'aurais le plus donc
que faire explique et essayer d'éviter
qu'il est ici sera content parce que
franchement quand je regarde l'arène
politique sur les questions
environnementales
en gros je dois choisir sur le mais je
dois choisir le mec qui dément de
conneries sur l'environnement et c'est
pas facile pas et je devrais pas choisir
entre les personnes qui commandent bien
ou quand je regarde un peu les histoires
qu'il raconte c'est souvent des trucs
qui techniquement sont imposables et en
fait je fais je fais comment le choix
politiques devraient être entre les
possibles pas entre les impossible donc
donc là tu parles pas mal de passer par
soit la politique soit le grand public
et son faux pressé par le grand public
pour atteindre la politique
j'ai l'impression en tout cas est-ce que
tu verras d'autres façons qui passent
pas par le grand public où les
politiques parce que c'est typique et ba
ba c'est compliqué et c'est une toute
petite hache et essayer des choses qu'on
résoudra pas tout seul mais c'est quand
même des changements de société et des
changements d'assez grande échelle donc
tu vois pas de solution à part passer
pour f1 après ba solution mais juste
d'autres façons d'aider bon on l'a déjà
dit a été actions individuelles ou qui
est ce que tu peux faire il ya la façon
dont tu consommes après il ya les gens
qui considèrent que j'ai des gens qui
parlent de l'environnement en
s'adressant aux personnes qui
considèrent avoir le plus influent ans
donc tu pourrais aller parler à des pdg
ces problèmes là et si tu arrives à
convaincre quelqu'un qui a une grande
entreprise peut être que tu es le levier
d'action sur ces questions et bien plus
grand que si tu arrives à convaincre
cent ou mille citoyens
donc en fait ça dépend à qui tu
t'adresses mai mais globalement le
changement climatique c'est elle à
l'érosion de la biodiversité etc
c'est quand même des problèmes de
pollution de masse par les masses donc
tu vois pas par exemple j'ai passé deux
parce qu'il y ait des mouvements
écologiques ils sont un peu plus et qui
sont problématiques et si je suis pas de
les sensibiliser aux aspects
scientifiques un peu plus bas c'est une
bonne question
alors ça c'est encore autre chose mais
pour moi ça fait partie de la
communication ça fait partie de démonter
certains discours et d'en produire
objectif basséen pas là quelque sorte le
même public s'est dit d'accord c'est pas
le même public
c'est des gens a effectivement il ya sas
pda il ya aussi tous les aspects
éducation parce que c'est quelque chose
qui manque en france parce que c'est des
sciences relativement récente qu'on n'a
pas nécessairement des compétences et ça
il ya des rapports
l'équipe du chiffre récemment qui
montrent que dans le supérieur il ya
très peu d'éducation là dessus donc en
fait les gens qui ont plus de poids
techniquement pour produire sélectionner
les discours ou mettre en place des
actions
ils ont les connaissances extrêmement
limité à dessus et donc ça c'est quelque
chose auquel on pourrait remédier et la
même façon on pourrait essayer
d'influencer les ong qui ont des
discours pas très scientifique où les
politiques qui ont eu des discours pas
très scientifique
moi honnêtement là dessus j'étais
désespéré il ya un an et j'ai
l'impression que les choses évoluent
crête
oui parce que en fait il ya quand même
j'ai l'impression à la fois de ce que je
vois autour de moi des gens qui me
contactent dans les commentaires et même
du traitement médiatique
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya plus en plus
de citoyens qui s'empare de cette
question est en fait de gens qui ne
viennent pas nécessairement de ces
milieux qui sont pas culturellement des
écolos je sais pas comment le dire
autrement donc qui arrive avec une
vision neutre et je sais pas j'ai le
message qui me disent mais je comprends
pas pourquoi les écolos ou tel problème
avec le nucléaire je comprends pas
pourquoi
et en fait ce sang neuf ça fait qu' il
ya des associations qui se forme qui
essaye d'avoir une approche objective et
qui arrivent sur des conclusions
différentes et qui commencent à
contester un peu certaines lignes des
oeufs durs des ong et j'ai moi je pense
vraiment que si on parle de politique si
on parle de discours à produire il va
falloir réussir à avoir un discours plus
factuel qu'aujourd'hui alors là c'est
mon billet si on tisse entre guillemets
il ya des gens qui racontent ce qu'ils
te diront que non il n'ya pas besoin
mais il ya besoin parce qu'à mon avis
c'est la seule chose qui permet de